Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
So, jetzt wird hier wieder Podcast gemacht. Bist du bereit für Arbeit?
Am Tag der Arbeit? Niemals.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 491 vom 1. Mai.
Also 30. April, 1. Mai, veröffentlicht am 1. Mai.
Kampftag der Arbeiterklasse. Da seht ihr mal, wir sind eigentlich auch immer in der Zukunft.
Ja, wir werden heute über die Datumsgrenze podcasten.
Genau. Ein Podcast, der vielleicht zwei Stunden lang ist, aber eigentlich 26 Stunden lang ist.
Ja.
Irgendwie sowas. Jetzt müssen wir nur noch irgendwie den Dreh rauskriegen,
warum wir das auskriegen am 1. Mai Datumsgrenze.
Ja, das ist die Revolution. Da beginnt die neue Zeitrechnung morgen.
Wir könnten natürlich so tun, als ob wir jetzt gerade auf dem Boot im Pazifik segeln.
Datumsgrenze kommt ja auch zu uns. Datumsgrenze? Datumsgrenze ist 0 Uhr.
Die Datumsgrenze ist ein Ort, keine Zeit.
Die Grenze ist in unseren Köpfen.
Freit euch von solchen Konzepten wie Zeit und Datum.
Ich übe schon mal für morgen.
Ja, genau. Auf jeden Fall haben wir so einen kleinen einen kleinen Zauberspruch
gemacht und jetzt ist Linus wieder da. Jetzt hast du ja endlich wieder Zeit
für die Sendung. Ist gut.
Ja, habe ich mich auch gefreut.
Ja, ist gut. Wurde schon nachgefragt.
Stimmt doch gar nicht. Keine Sau hat nachgefragt.
Doch, klar.
Nein. Doch.
Ich habe gefragt.
Ach ja. Ja, Tag der Arbeit. Und was, also weiß ich nicht.
Ich gehe morgen in den Grunewald, natürlich.
Zum Mai-Gruni.
Und dann...
Razzia im Willen.
Und dann werden... Was wird dann...
Weißt du, wie meine Bezugsgruppe heißt? Die habe ich schon benannt.
Anne Broer-Hilka Ultras.
Anne? Bro? Was?
Sorry, ich bin...
Weißt du nicht, wer Anne Broer-Hilka ist?
Keine Ahnung.
Das ist die Staatsanwältin, die den Cum-Ex-Skandal aufgeklärt hat.
Und die jetzt nicht mehr weitermachen will.
Genau, vor einem halben Jahr gab es da, da sollte ihr die, das haben wir wahrscheinlich
auch in der Sendung behandelt, da sollte ihr die Abteilung halbiert werden oder so.
Und die hat jetzt die Staatsanwaltschaft verlassen, um die Entlassung aus dem,
Beamtenstatus, den sie dort hat.
Gebeten und wird wird sich offenbar als Direktorin der NGO Finanzwende zukünftig
engagieren, um das Problem anders zu bekämpfen, denn als Staatsanwältin. Faszinierend.
Die hat gegen viele Widerstände mit großem Nachdruck diese ganze Cum-Ex-Sache
aufgeklärt, untersucht, herausgefunden.
Die Verfahren geführt, in denen erstmal festgestellt wird, dass das strafbar ist.
Und die hatte gegen sich diese, also neben dem Hanno Berger,
der sich den Kram ausgedacht hat, der ja vorher Steuerprüfer war,
glaube ich, Steuerprüfer oder Berater, weiß ich nicht genau.
Ne, der war auf jeden Fall Steuerprüfer oder Steuerfahnder, der sich den ganzen
Kram ausgedacht hat, dann halt die Seiten gewechselt hat auf die dunkle Seite der Macht.
Diese Steuerbetrugsmasche sich hat einfallen lassen oder auch diese Rechtsanwaltskanzlei
Freshfields, die das Gutachten geliefert haben, das erklärt hat,
das wäre also völlig legal,
sich einmal gezahlte Steuern mehrfach erstatten zu lassen.
Ja, wo du auch denkst, wie kommst du denn an, wie viel muss ich einem Anwalt
geben, dass der so eine Scheiße schreibt.
Naja, okay. Und gegen die hat die sich alle durchgesetzt, auf einer Staatsanwältinnenposten,
mit den entsprechenden Ressourcen und der entsprechenden Bezahlung.
Und hat jetzt leider entnervt aufgegeben. Nee, sorry.
Die hat nicht aufgegeben. Die hat entschieden, dass sie ihre Zeit besser verwenden
kann, als in diesem jahrelangen Verfahren.
Aufgeben zu unterstellen wäre völlig falsch, weil bei der Finanzwende wird sie
ja jetzt weiter sich diesem Thema widmen.
Genau, und das in der Rolle der Geschäftsführerin der Finanzwende,
was bemerkenswert ist, wie ich finde.
Das heißt, der Laden kann jetzt, der kriegt jetzt erstmal die Bücher geprüft. Nein, Quatsch.
Ja, das kann natürlich auch passieren.
Ja, weil er war ein absolutes Vorbild in Idealismus und Durchhaltepower.
Also was die, welche Winde dieser Frau über die Jahre ins Gesicht geweht haben
und mit wem die sich angelegt hat und dann wird sie irgendwie vor einem halben
Jahr da auch noch von ihrem neuen Vorgesetzten da gebackstabbt,
der irgendwie offenbar nicht weiß,
was er da gerade für eine Ausnahmestaatsanwältin hat.
Oder genau weiß, dass er da eine Ausnahmestaatsanwältin hat.
Auf jeden Fall von den eigenen Leuten, von den eigenen Vorgesetzten offenbar nicht unterstützt.
Das ist schon irre.
Ja, aber du weißt doch, unsere Politik möchte doch gerne die Bürger entlasten.
Ja, und den Kanzler, der sich an den Scheiß nicht mehr erinnern kann.
Naja, und auch halt andere Leute, die vom Steuersystem auf eine Art und Weise
profitiert haben, wie es eigentlich nicht vorgesehen war.
Also das ist wirklich eine interessante Personalie und ich frage mich,
ob es letzten Endes auch bedeuten kann, dass man irgendwie in der NGO vielleicht
mehr bewirken kann, als in der Staatsanwaltschaft.
Das wird das zeigen.
Ja, also das, genau das, wird sich das sehr gut überlegt haben.
Das kann ich mir auch vorstellen und jetzt muss sie in gewisser Hinsicht halt
auch, also das ein oder andere Blatt vor dem Mund kann sie jetzt wahrscheinlich entfernen.
Ja, vielleicht Ihr entscheidendes Zitat, weil mich das gerade so ärgert,
dass ich das mit dem Aufgeben gesagt habe.
Ich war immer mit Leib und Seele Staatsanwältin, gerade im Bereich von Wirtschaftskriminalität.
Aber ich bin überhaupt nicht zufrieden damit, wie in Deutschland Finanzkriminalität verfolgt wird.
Da geht es oft um Täter mit viel Geld und guten Kontakten und Treffen auf eine
schwach aufgestellte Justiz.
Und dann kommt es eben oft dazu, dass sie sich aus den Verfahren schlicht herauskaufen
können. Es birgt die Gefahr, dass die Allgemeinheit das Vertrauen in den Rechtsstaat verliert.
Ja, muss man sich echt mal anschauen, was, was, damit auseinandersetzen,
was die da alles so gemacht hat, wie sie da dran geblieben ist.
Ja, gut.
Wir wollen noch einen Termin ankündigen, Tim.
Jetzt schon?
Haben wir doch gerade gesagt, oder nicht?
Okay, ich dachte, wir machen das in den Termin.
Ja, nee, das würde ich nicht machen, weil da schlafen die Leute ja schon.
Meinst du echt? Bei unserem Podcast geht keiner ein.
Also, wir machen ein Save the Date. Save the Data habe ich jetzt gerade geschrieben.
Zweites Mal, das ist wirklich im Kopf. Save the Date. 31.
August,
2024, also dieses Jahr, haben wir was vor mit euch und Und wir wollen noch nicht
sagen irgendwas, aber wir wollen, dass ihr euch den Termin schon mal eintragt. Es ist ein Samstag.
Samstag in Berlin.
Wahrscheinlich in Berlin.
Ziemlich wahrscheinlich in Berlin.
Ich schreibe hin, ziemlich wahrscheinlich in Berlin.
Genau.
Da könntet ihr jetzt mal überlegen, ob ihr da in Berlin seid und bleiben möchtet
oder nach Berlin kommen möchtet.
Das wäre also eine Option. Der 31. August wäre ein günstiger Tag.
Ja, und hat was mit physischer Präsenz zu tun.
Ja.
Nicht irgend so ein Internetgedöns. Ja. Da gibt es ja auch immer mehr von.
Diese Leute, die den ganzen Tag nur Ja.
Alles virtuell, alles egal, wo man ist, alles remote. Alle sitzen nur noch auf der Insel und so.
Nicht bei uns.
Ich habe ja eh schon in unserer gemeinsamen letzten Sendung bemängelt,
dass das Internet undankbar ist.
Und dabei bleibe ich.
Aber möchtest du ein Feedback verlesen, Tim?
Ja, also Ich hatte mich Oder soll ich es verlesen?
Ja, das kannst du ja mal machen, ich war ja auf Reisen davon habe ich ein bisschen
berichtet ein bisschen Genau.
Ihr hattet zum Anfang der letzten Sendung einen Scherz gemacht,
über Regenfälle an deinem zu dem Zeitpunkt Standort Ja, mein Aufenthaltsort
Du hast über das Wetter vor Ort gewitzelt.
Dazu wurde kommentiert, findet ihr den lustigen Einstieg zu Überschwemmungen
in Dubai nicht etwas sehr geschmacklos?
Da ist die Jahresmenge Regen auf einmal runtergekommen, es gab heftige Schäden und Tote.
Lässt sich vielleicht nicht eins zu eins auf die Flutkatastrophe 2021 in unter
anderem den Westen Deutschlands übertragen,
aber zumindest die gleichen Eckpunkte, extreme Niederstärksmengen,
die zu großer Zerstörung und Toten geführt haben, sind ähnlich.
Wenn ihr auch der Meinung seid, dass damals so ein Kicher unangebracht gewesen
wäre, warum meint ihr, dass das jetzt in Ordnung ist?
Also, die Frage richtet sich an Thomas und Tim.
Du bist fein raus.
Ich bin fein raus.
Also, ich kann ja mal einen Einstieg machen.
Also, Flutkatastrophe 2021 zu Ahrtal und so. Das ist damit gemeint. Im Vergleich. gleich.
Ich muss tatsächlich, also ich muss wirklich sagen, ich habe von diesen Regenfällen
in Dubai oder der Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate überhaupt nichts mitbekommen.
Wirklich nicht. Mir ist dieser Sachverhalt unbekannt. Gab es da Tote?
Ja.
Wie viele?
In Dubai?
Also in Dubai.
Insgesamt. Es wird von 18 Toten in Oman berichtet und von einem in Dubai.
Und hast du die verunglimpft?
Nein.
Habt ihr am Anfang der Sendung irgendwie über deren, also habt ihr das in irgendeiner
Form relativiert oder so?
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, was ich denn, guck mal, ich war da.
Und du hast aber überlebt.
Ich hab überlebt.
Das ist eine gute Nachricht.
Ich war auch, sagen wir mal, zu Beginn des ganzen Spiels war ich auch in einem sicheren Bereich.
Spiels? Du warst dann schon wieder zum Fußball gucken?
Nein, also als es sich das so entsponnen. Also es gab noch Zeit,
das herannahende Gewitter mit einem schönen Zeitraffer-Video vom Balkon des
Hotels aufzunehmen. Ja. Sowas.
Und, also es hat da viel geregnet. Es hat da mehr geregnet, als es jemals in
Dubai oder in den Vereinigten Arabischen Emiraten oder in dieser ganzen Region jemals geregnet hat.
Soweit man weiß, also seit Beginn der Aufzeichnung.
Wie es so schön heißt.
Und selbstverständlich waren da viele sehr überrascht, aber das war keine Ahrtal-Katastrophe.
Also zumindest nicht dort, wo ich war.
Also ich glaube, bei einem durchschnittlichen Sturm in Deutschland gehen mehrere Personen drauf.
Ja, und Leute, das ist ja auch, das kann ja auch alles sein und das ist sicherlich
für die Betroffenen ist das ja auch ein großes Drama und schlimm und da habe
ich mich überhaupt nicht zu geäußert.
Das ist, das ist, denke ich, der entscheidende Punkt. Du hast,
ich habe dich nicht, ich habe gehört, dass du dich darüber beklagt hast, dass du...
Dahin fliegst und schlechtes Wetter ist. Es gibt auch andere,
um den Umgang mal, es gibt auch einen anderen Kommentar, der sagt,
ey, die Pointe schreibt sich doch wirklich wie von selbst,
in Linz ist Wetter wie in Dubai.
Also es gibt auch Leute, die jetzt hier andere humoristische Perspektiven nahelegen.
Also erstmal, dieser Vergleich mit der Flugkatastrophe, im Ahrtal,
ja, also der ist, sagen wir mal jetzt erstmal faktisch, da hat nicht dasselbe stattgefunden.
Da gab es jetzt zwar viel Regen, aber dieser Regen hat sich im Wesentlichen
auf den Straßen gesammelt und die Autos sind abgesoffen.
Ja, irgendwo hat sich auch so viel Wasser angesammelt und dann ist halt jemand
tatsächlich in seinem Auto, vermutlich, keine Ahnung, ich kenne diesen Einzelfall
jetzt so genau nicht, ist da jemand tatsächlich ums Leben gekommen.
Das ist scheiße für diese Person,
aber da habe ich jetzt nichts mit zu tun und das ist dann auch nicht meine Perspektive
auf dieses Ereignis, weil es gibt natürlich viele Perspektiven,
die man einnehmen kann auf dieses Ereignis.
Aber diese Pflicht sozusagen immer so von der Maximalbetroffenheit von irgendjemand
auszugehen und das wäre dann sozusagen die einzige Perspektive,
aus der man das betrachten kann, da gehe ich jetzt so nicht mit.
So, weil man kann natürlich immer über alles extrem betroffen sein und in seiner
Betroffenheit dann auch ersaufen förmlich, aber das bringt einen ja auch nicht weiter.
Sondern man muss ja dann irgendwie auch eine gewisse Distanz einnehmen und vor
allem darf man seinen Humor nicht verlieren.
Also ich hätte, ich muss wirklich sagen, wenn du jetzt Witze über den Tod von
Menschen gemacht hättest, hätte ich das auch geschmacklos gefunden,
aber ich habe einfach überhaupt nichts gehört.
Du hast, ihr habt darüber gewitzelt, dass du in eine Wüste fährst und da Regenschauer
ist und das ist schon, das ist glaube ich, ohne das jetzt genau benennen zu
können, würde ich sagen, dass es eine Reihe an Cartoons gibt,
die eine solche Situation schon humoristisch aufbearbeitet haben.
Aber was ich an diesem Kommentar auch ein bisschen wahrnehme,
ist etwas, was mir auch wirklich ...
Ja, ich habe vor, ich glaube das ist wahrscheinlich inzwischen über zehn Jahre
her, Vorträge über Internetdiskussionen gehalten.
Ja, ich glaube irgendwie so die Kunst des Trollens oder so.
Ich habe immer bei dem Easter Hack und so, wo ich mich ein bisschen darüber
auch lustig mache, wie Menschen in Internetdiskussionen so hochrot werden.
Und wie das so eskaliert und wie die sich in so Themen festbeißen.
Und wie die dann so jeden anpaulen, der irgendwas zu diesem Thema sagt.
Und ich habe das auch beobachtet im Nachgang zu unserer Sendung zum Anzeigen Hauptmeister,
wo sich dann motorisierte Gewalt und da hat sich dann dieser gesamte Kampf zwischen
Radfahrern und Autofahrern und all der dort angestaute Hass auch noch in unserer
Kommentarspalte. ergossen.
Jetzt muss ich dazu sagen, ich bin Radfahrer, ich habe mehrere Radfahrer auch in der Sendung erzählt.
Und ich habe auch heute mich wieder fürchterlich darüber aufgeregt,
dass mich jemand fast umgenietet hat auf dem Weg hier in die Metaebene.
Aber ich kann nicht dieses Thema in jedes Gespräch reinbringen und irgendwie
eine Betroffenheit Betroffenheit oder eine Betroffenheit verlangen oder eine Anklage erheben,
insbesondere wenn das einfach mal gerade nicht Thema war.
Wir haben nicht darüber gesprochen, dass irgendjemand Gewalt ausübt, indem er fährt.
Wir haben über parkende Autos gesprochen. Ja.
Ziehen, Parallelen zum Dritten Reich.
Ja, also ich glaube, das war sogar du. Was?
Quasi gehorsam. Das ist ja sowieso klar, dass Parallelen zum Dritten Reich,
also Godwin diskutiert ja immer mit, aber wenn jemand, der so,
gesetzeshörig ist und nicht den eigenen Verstand einschaltet und so weiter, da kommen alle diese,
Verkrampftheit rein. Und man
kann nicht mehr einfach sich zusammen zurücklehnen und über etwas lachen.
Ich muss wirklich sagen, dass mich das, also ich kann das nicht.
Es ist auch noch ein bisschen, es geht noch weiter. Es wird auch in gewisser Hinsicht gefordert,
dass man, also einerseits muss man zu allem eine Position haben.
Also man kann nicht irgendwas an sich vorbeiziehen lassen und man kann auch
mal nicht keine Meinung haben, sondern es muss immer irgendwas,
irgendeine Haltung geben dazu und wenn man die dann nicht hat,
Also wenn man keine hat, die dann dem jeweiligen Betrachter dann auch nicht passt,
dann ist das halt auch schlimm und dann zeigt das schon irgendwas und dann ist
das bedrohlich für sich nochmal und es wird auch überhaupt gar keinen Raum gegeben zu lernen.
Ich folge so einem Account, TIL, man kann ja nicht mal so Accounts sagen wie
früher bei Twitter, dass noch alles gut war.
Du findest Twitter gut.
Dann magst du auch Elon Musk.
Und dann kommen immer so lustige Sachen raus.
So, ja, heute hab ich das gelernt, dass hier irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
dieses Medikament wurde erfunden, weil diese lustige Sache auf einem Kreuzfahrtschiff
passiert ist oder so, keine Ahnung.
Und dann kam auf einmal Today I learned that in 2001 two planes crashed into
the World Trade Center in New York.
Und das war der Post. Und ich dachte mir so,
ich weiß gar nicht genau, was ich mir in dem Moment dachte, aber ich dachte
mir so, da will ich jetzt mal sehen, was da an Feedback zukam.
Mal gucken, wie das Internet dir das dankt. Mal gucken, wie das Internet damit umgeht.
Nochmal kurz zu dem Post. Der war korrekt recherchiert. Das stimmt,
ich kann das bestätigen.
Das war 2001.
Da sind Flugzeuge.
Der wusste wahrscheinlich sogar, der hat wahrscheinlich sogar das Datum dazu benennen können.
Ja.
Ich glaube 11. September.
Korrekt. So. Und das ist passiert. In New York. In den USA.
In den USA?
Ja, in den USA.
Wo kamen die Flugzeuge denn her? her.
Aus dem Himmel. Ja.
Ist passiert. So. Erste Antwort, die ich gefunden habe.
Lösche diesen Post. Es ist eine Verhöhnung der Opfer. Auf Englisch.
Aber ich sag mal so...
2001, ja, das ist jetzt fast, also das ist jetzt 22,5 Jahre her.
Bisschen mehr als 12 Jahre her.
22 Jahre her. 22 Jahre.
Stell dir mal vor, ich weiß ja überhaupt nicht, wer diesen Account schreibt.
Wer lernt denn die ganze Zeit irgendwas im Internet? Das sind ja meistens Leute,
die wie soll ich sagen, eine gewisse Aufgeschlossenheit neuen Informationen gegenüber bringen.
Und wenn Wenn jemand so aufwächst und was weiß ich, 16 oder 17,
18, keine Ahnung, irgendein Alter, irgendein junges Alter hat,
dann ist etwas, was vor 22 Jahren passiert,
nichts, was man zwangsläufig in die Wiege gelegt bekommt.
Irgendwie könnte man ja auch die Annahme machen, naja, du schreibst ja da auf
Englisch, also musst du aus den USA sein.
Wenn die Person aus den USA ist, dann hätte sie von 9-11 gelernt,
bevor sie gelernt hat zu schreiben.
Also die Person ist vermutlich nicht aus den USA.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Oder sie benutzt so eine Diktierfunktion.
Also selbst wenn, es ist völlig unerheblich.
Irgendwann muss es ja jeder Mensch mal lernen.
Ja, genau. Genau. Und dann lernt man was.
Alle, die damals, also die meisten Leute haben es gelernt an dem Tag selber.
Ja, das ist ein Event, was unüber, habe ich nicht mitbekommen war.
Aber natürlich ein Mensch, der danach geboren ist oder zu dem Zeitpunkt noch
nicht die kognitiven Fähigkeiten hatte, Situationen zu analysieren und sich
zu merken, muss das ja irgendwann mal lernen.
Ja und vor allem selbst wenn du diese Information als solche wahrnimmst,
ist überhaupt nicht gesagt,
dass jemand der das 20, 30 Jahre später erfährt, dass er diesem Ereignis dieselbe
Bedeutung zu widmet, wie das in dem Moment war.
Weil die Welt hat sich ja in diesen 20 Jahren,
nicht zuletzt durch dieses Ereignis, erheblich verändert und neue Realitäten
sind aufgetreten und da mag einiges darauf zurückzuführen sein,
aber was jetzt davon darauf zurückzuführen ist, weißt du ja nicht.
Ja, wenn man das Alter, was du da so hast, voraussetzt, irgendwo so im Bereich 16 Jahre,
dann konnte die Person sich die letzten vier Jahre erstmal mit einer Pandemie
und mit irgendwie Angriffen Russlands auf die Ukraine und Nahostkonflikt und
so einem Scheiß auseinandersetzen, seit sie zwölf ist.
Und dann kommt das schon irgendwie hin. Also es ist ja völlig klar,
dass jeder Mensch das irgendwann mal lernen muss, wenn dieser Mensch jünger
ist als das, was da passiert ist.
Natürlich wirkt das auf jemanden wie mich, der dieses Event miterlebt hat,
der in dem Land gewohnt hat.
Ziemlich absurd, dass das jemand nicht weiß, aber man muss schon die eine Sekunde haben,
um kurz drüber nachzudenken, dass es halt jüngere Menschen gibt.
Man hält sich ja immer für den Jüngsten.
Und die anderen einfach nur für klein und doof.
Aber daraus eine Verhöhnung der Opfer zu konstruieren, ist ja das Verrückte
an dieser Stelle wieder. Genau.
Es ist eine Anmaßung und es ist vor allem auch so eine Sicht,
wie soll ich das mal nennen, so eine, also sozusagen nur eine einzige Perspektive
darauf wird irgendwie zugelassen.
Ja, die dann irgendwie als die Wahrheit oder die einzig mögliche,
wie kann man da nur irgendein anderes Verhältnis zu haben, als das,
was ich jetzt gerade denke.
Und sicherlich gibt es Ereignisse, wo sich, sagen wir mal, der Interpretationsspielraum
ein bisschen weiter einengt, aber wir sehen das ja auch gerade bei den aktuellen
Ereignissen und wie die diskutiert werden,
dass es sehr wohl Leute gibt, die da alle möglichen Perspektiven darauf haben.
Und da machen wir auch Witze drüber.
Da machen wir auch Witze drüber. Wir machen hier sowieso über alles Witze.
Wir machen über alles Witze und ich halte das für absolut essentiell.
Und also die häufigste Frage, die Leute mir zu Logbuch-Netzpolitik stellen,
wenn ich sie irgendwo treffe, was weiß ich, bei einem Event oder sonst was.
Die häufigste Frage, die Leute mir stellen ist, wie schafft ihr das,
so viele Jahre lang so gute Laune beim Verbreiten so schlechter Nachrichten zu haben?
Das ist das Primärfeedback oder auch wenn ich so Grußkarten,
Aufmerksamkeiten von irgendeiner Wunschliste oder so, es ist meistens,
dass die Leute uns da für die humoristische Perspektive auf eigentlich fürchterliches Geschehen danken.
Und ich kann eigentlich nur sagen, das ist die einzige Möglichkeit, damit umzugehen.
Humor ist ja die einzige Waffe, die du hast.
Das ist die einzige letzte Waffe, weil du am Boden liegst und du hast alles verloren.
Humor ist das eine Ding, was dir noch bleibt. Das können die nicht aus dir rausbringen,
das können sie dir nicht nehmen.
Und das ist absolut entscheidend, weil wenn du diesen Humor verlierst,
hast du auch die Chance verloren,
noch irgendwo zu gewinnen, weil du nur noch verbissen bist und weil du dann
auch angreifbar bist, wenn du verbissen bist.
Ja und guck dir mal an, was für Leute, ich meine guck dir doch mal den König der Humorlosen an.
Welchen?
Donald Trump. Der Typ, der hat ja noch nie gelacht.
Genau.
Der kann gar nicht lachen.
Der kann auch keinen Witz erzählen.
Nein.
Der ist überhaupt nicht in der Lage, Humor auch nur in irgendeiner Form zu produzieren,
weil alles in seiner Welt, es geht nur um ihn und alles ist überhaupt nur durch
seine eigene Perspektive definiert.
Und das sind dann auch wirklich die gefährlichsten Leute.
Und das Einzige, was er allenfalls, ich glaube, wenn er seine Versuche an Humor,
sind dann irgendwelche hämischen Verunglimpfungen anderer Menschen.
Also irgendwie Sleepy Joe oder ich glaube von irgendeinem anderen Präsidentschaftskandidaten
hat er gesagt, seine Ehepartnerin sähe nicht so gut aus wie seine.
Das ist so das Höchste, was der Donald Trump an Humor hinbekommt.
Aber wirklich, also Humor ist das Einzige, was uns bleibt.
Und es gibt Ricky Gervais, den ich sehr verehre für seinen Humor,
der erzählt in einer seiner Nummern oder wie man das auch nennt,
welche Witze sie bei der Beerdigung seiner Mutter gemacht haben.
Und das ist genau das Richtige.
Das ist genau das Richtige, dass man an einem solchen Tag Witze macht und dass
man an einem solchen Tag die Härte nimmt. Der Tag ist hart genug.
Und diese Verbissenheit in Themen ist genau das Falsche.
Und jeder, der dieser Verbissenheit anheimfällt, muss das reflektieren und sich davor schützen,
weil das macht graue Gesichter, das macht Falten, das macht traurig,
das macht Ränder unter den Augen, das macht scheiß Tage und unterm Ende summiert
sich das auf ein scheiß Leben,
wenn man sich den Humor nehmen lässt.
Und das ist wirklich eine feste Überzeugung, die mich in meinem Leben durch
dunkle Zeiten getragen hat, dass ich immer wieder versucht habe,
irgendwie eine humorvolle Perspektive auf Dinge zu haben.
Deswegen verstehe ich da keinen Spaß bei dem Thema.
Also, ich werde auch, wenn auf meiner Beerdigung nicht ordentlich Witze gekloppt
werden, dann bin ich aber auch sauer.
Wenn nicht auf meinem Grab getanzt wird, ist es nicht meine Beerdigung.
Ja, also ich meine, Humor ist in gewisser Hinsicht, das ist natürlich auch...
Es ist auch ein Werkzeug so, weil es baut auch Brücken.
Und in dieser ganzen verkrampften Diskussionskultur, die das Internet leider mit aufgebracht hat,
in der Leute sich nicht nur missverstehen, sondern in gewisser Hinsicht auch missverstehen wollen,
wird ein Streit herbeigeführt, der unnötig ist.
Du kennst sicherlich, ich hoffe wir finden den passenden Link,
aber du hast das bestimmt gesehen, es gibt dieses wunderbare GIF,
wo so zwei Hunde durch so ein Tor sich ankläffen, wirklich wie aufs Blut,
als würden sie sich gleich am liebsten die Nase abbeißen.
Und dann macht einer das Tor so auf und sie stehen so direkt voreinander und
dann so, sind sie so, war was?
Und das ist aber so dieses, wie wir uns im Internet verhalten und wie wir uns
im wahren Leben unterhalten.
Also das ist so eine Kultur, die dieses gesichtslose, ich weiß nicht,
wir hatten ja immer die Anonymität im Internet ist eine Gefahr und so weiter.
Also mittlerweile wissen wir, die Anonymität ist definitiv nicht das Problem,
aber ich glaube dieser Mangel an Unmittelbarkeit, so dieses Unfysische,
was das Netz dann doch letzten Endes mit sich bringt.
Diese Beliebigkeit, dass man Leute eigentlich gar nicht mehr als Menschen wirklich
wahrnimmt, wenn sie nur durch Avatare abgebildet sind.
Das ist etwas, wo man aufpassen muss und wo ich mir auch ehrlich gesagt nicht ganz so sicher bin.
Dass nochmal signifikant besser werden kann.
Ich denke, wir werden in gewisser Hinsicht und sind wahrscheinlich auch schon
ein bisschen auf dem Weg,
so eine Rückbesinnung haben auf nicht-digitale Traditionen, weil das so eine
Sogwirkung erzeugen wird irgendwann.
Teilweise findet das sicherlich schon statt. Also auch diese Corona-Zeit,
wo dann sozusagen dieses Treffen überhaupt nicht mehr da war.
Das hat ja manche Leute dann komplett über die Kante gestoßen.
So und eine entsprechende Gegenbewegung ist ja glaube ich ganz sinnvoll.
Und ich habe Podcasts immer sehr geschätzt in ihrer Diskussions- und Kommentarkultur.
Generell, das ist auch nach wie vor so, denke ich mal, weil es schon ganz hilfreich ist,
dass man sich so viel Zeit für Podcasts nimmt, sowohl jetzt auf der produzierenden
als auch auf der konsumierenden Seite und dass das eben schon zu einer deutlich.
Besseren Verständigung führt. Ja.
Insofern, behaltet euren Humor. Das ist wichtig, ja.
Es ist wirklich wichtig. Humor ist auch der Ausdruck davon, dass man zu einem
Thema zumindest eine, also.
Distanz schaffen kann?
Ja, und auch, sagen wir mal, eine emotional gesunde Beziehung hat.
Die Dinge über die Menschen, also es gibt, natürlich gibt es ein paar Themen,
wo man echt lieber mal keine Witze drüber macht oder wo man die Witze anderen überlässt.
Also es gibt bestimmte Phänomenbereiche, die im Bereich der Diskriminierung
sind, da überlässt man die Witze lieber den Diskriminierten.
Die machen einfach auch die Besseren. Mhm.
Aber genau da zeigt sich ja, dass sie auch eine gesunde Distanz und einen unverkrampften
Umgang mit einem Thema haben.
Und ich denke, das ist also die Fähigkeit, über etwas zu lachen,
ist so wirklich ein Messwert von, hast du da einen emotional groben,
also bist du da frei von emotionalen Verkrampfungen oder Verklemmungen mit dem Thema.
Und es gibt Dinge, über die man zu unterschiedlichen Zeitpunkten im Leben nicht
lachen kann, ja, was weiß ich, ähm.
Tod nahe Angehöriger, schwere Verletzungen, schwere Rückschläge, Trennungen.
Aber der Zielzustand, den man seelisch haben will in einer solchen Situation,
da wo man hin muss, ist immer wieder, dass man darüber lachen kann.
Sagt man auch sogar, hey, komm, heute kommt das hart vor, aber in zwei Jahren
sitzen wir hier und lachen.
Und das ist, lachen zu können ist ein Ausdruck einer gesunden seelischen Beziehung zu einem Sachverhalt.
Und deswegen muss man auch das anstreben und auch in sich selber reingehen und
denken so, ey, was sind diese Themen, wo ich verkrampft werde,
wo ich nicht mehr lachen kann, wo ich irgendwie ernst werde.
Und man hat zu jedem Zeitpunkt seines Lebens, hat man ja welche,
wo man merkt, ah shit, da habe ich gerade einen wunden Punkt.
Wenn ich da jetzt drüber rede, wenn ich darüber rede, dann geht das Gespräch schief.
Ja, dann, das hab ich ja jetzt zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt auch,
sag ich dir jetzt aber nicht, weil, ne, aber da muss man,
da ist der Imperativ, ist sofort darüber nachzudenken, wie man da wieder rauskommt,
wie man darüber lachen kann, wie man Abstand dazu gewinnen kann und wie man
das verarbeitet, um wieder einen unverkrampften Umgang damit zu finden.
Und insofern betrachte ich vieles von dem, was ich an irgendwelchen Ausrastern
im Internet wahrnehme, teilweise,
also häufig einfach nur mit Mitleid, dass ich denke, oh scheiße,
die Person muss das Ding gerade verarbeiten.
Ja, aber was ich wirklich mit Sorge betrachte ist, dass Leute sich da gegenseitig
drin befeuern und irgendwie so um die Wette keinen Humor haben.
Guck mal, ich habe eine noch humorlosere Perspektive. Ich kann hier noch fünf
Tote mit ins Feld führen, die auch noch verunglimpft wurden.
Und außerdem kann ich hier noch einen entfernten Suizid in der Familie mit reinbringen,
um die Stimmung mal richtig hier in den Keller zu drücken.
Tja, wer hier hat noch irgendjemand Spaß?
Ja. Ja.
Und ich frage mich ernsthaft, wohin mit dieser Einstellung, in welche Richtung
soll diese Revolution gehen?
Deswegen fahre ich auch morgen nach Grunewald zur Spaßdemonstration der hedonistischen Internationale.
Das ist das, was für mich eine vernünftige Perspektive zum Ausdruck bringt und
ein halbwegs unverkrampften Umgang mit einem echt ernsten Thema.
Klar müssen wir die enteignen. Und wenn irgendwann nicht mehr so viele Polizisten
kommen, dann legen wir Grunewald in Schutt und Asche.
Und bis dahin, ja, machen wir uns einfach schöne, lustige Sonntage.
So, wollen wir mal, kommen wir zu den ganzen Themen.
Na endlich. nicht.
Das ist die ganze Betroffenheit hier.
Sollen wir die Kapell-Marke wirklich Arschverletztheit und Humor im Angesicht
des Todes benennen? Können wir ja nochmal überlegen.
Naja.
Also.
So, wir müssen mal noch Wikipedia eintrachten. 9-11 müssen wir noch in die Show schreiben.
Damit die Leute auch wissen.
Worüber wir reden. Das war bei uns bisher selten Thema.
Wir haben ja noch nicht drüber berichtet. Das war so kein Schweinbescheid.
Das fängt ja gut an.
Also, es gibt, ich räume jetzt mal so ein bisschen Themen auf,
die in den letzten Wochen nicht behandelt wurden.
Das lag daran, dass häufig Thomas ist mir mal eingesprungen, dann die Sabrina und so.
Diese Themen, wo ich denke, die sollte man hier nochmal ein bisschen besprechen.
Genau, wir wollten ja auch ein bisschen noch was für dich übrig lassen,
dass du auch was zu erzählen hast, nicht dass du hier so Themennot kriegst oder so.
Lieb von euch.
Genau, wir fangen mit der XZ Backdoor an, die ja, wie die Bild-Zeitung gleich
schrieb, irgendwie durch einen, wo ein Deutscher das Internet gerettet hat.
Es ging um Millisekunden.
Das war einfach alles kurz vor Flutung.
Naja, also was der da gefunden hat, ist schon irre. Weil es jetzt einige Zeit
her ist, ich sag's mal zu Beginn, ich erhebe jetzt hier keinen Anspruch auf
technische Detailtreue.
Es geht eher darum, dieses Thema jetzt mal dem Massenpublikum,
das wir ja hier erreichen, zu verdeutlichen.
Diejenigen, die sich technisch damit dafür interessiert haben,
haben es ja ohnehin bis jetzt im Zweifelsfall dieses Wissen auf anderen Wegen erlangt.
Ja, ich habe schon mal in der Freakshow versucht, das irgendwie zusammenzufassen,
aber jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, wie du das zusammenfasst.
Das ist richtig, ja.
Raus!
Da verstehe ich wirklich keinen Spaß. Also,
Fangen wir mal an, aus dem Blick dieses Menschen, der bei Microsoft gearbeitet
hat, immer noch, wahrscheinlich, also ich vermute, er durfte seinen Job behalten,
hat da irgendwie, ich glaube, Postgres-Server gemacht, hat sich auf...
Das ist übrigens ganz interessant, es gab so wirklich drei Betrachtungsperspektiven.
Postgres-Developer hat den Bug gefunden, Microsoft-Mitarbeiter hat es gefunden
oder ein Deutscher. Ja, alle drei.
Aber jeder hat so ein bisschen seinen eigenen Kanal.
Sein Bild, ja. Ich glaube, die ganzen Linuxer haben am wenigsten darauf gezeigt,
dass das ein Microsoft-Entwickler war.
Genau, aber fangen wir mal von vorne an.
Der stellte fest, dass er bei seinem Management von Systemen irgendwie auf einmal
längere Verzögerungen hatte beim Herstellen von SSH-Verbindungen.
Und zwar auf einem Testsystem, das er gerade neu gemacht hat.
Tatsächlich wirklich irre, dass ihm das überhaupt aufgefallen ist.
Das zeigt einfach, dass er da wirklich sehr gute Tests hat und enorm auf jede
Abweichung da geachtet hat.
Und dann fällt ihm auf, okay, das ist sehr komisch, diese SSH-Verbindung hat
eine lange Verzögerung und da geht auch irgendwie kurz die CPU-Last auf den Systemen hoch.
Und er findet im Prinzip damit einen Bug in SSH auf diesen Testsystemen,
die aus ich weiß nicht genau welche Linux-Distribution er da genutzt hat, aber die quasi aus den,
Beta-Testing-Instable Und dann taucht er diesem Bug hinterher und entdeckt etwas,
was sich dann am Ende herausstellt als eine absichtlich platzierte Schwachstelle
in einer Softwarebibliothek mit dem Namen XZ.
XZ ist ein, eher so im FreeBSD-Bereich finde ich hauptsächlich eher so XZ-komprimierte Daten.
Also es ist ein Komprimierungsalgorithmus.
Von denen es ja viele gibt, die also einfach zum Ziel haben,
Dateigrößen zu komprimieren, etwas kleiner zu machen.
Und diese XZ-Library ist eine Dependency von SSH, der Secure Shell. Was heißt Dependency?
Bereitstellt, sodass man sie in anderen Programmen auch nutzen kann.
Und dann schreibe ich quasi mein Programm und sage, dieses Programm bekommt
übrigens, nutzt auch die Library von XZ und dann kann ich in meinem Programm,
wiederum XZ benutzen.
Also XZ ist so ein Kompressionsalgorithmus, der macht halt Daten kleiner und
das ist so, wenn man mal so Gzip benutzt hat, so Bzip2, solche Tools,
also Genau, das sind alles GZ-Dateien, erstellt halt einfach,
ich will das kleiner machen, komprimier mir das mal,
wirft Daten weg, die man jetzt zur Wiederherstellung des vollständigen Inhalts
so nicht braucht und dann wird die Datei halt einfach kleiner.
Du hast da irgendwie, was weiß ich, ganz viele Spaces in deinem Dokument,
da kann man das irgendwie auch alles besser zusammenfassen.
Erkennt Patterns, genau. Also Kompressor. Und jetzt findet dieser Microsoft-Entwickler irre...
Der Deutsche.
Der Deutsche findet vom Chinesen platziert... Findet also, dass es in dem Code von XZ...
Eine Änderung gibt, die dazu führt, dass wenn XZ verwendet wird im Kontext von SSH,
potenziell eine Verschlüsselungsoperation gestört wird, oder eine kryptografische
Operation gestört wird, die am Ende potenziell dazu führen könnte,
dass man sich anmelden kann,
ohne den richtigen Key oder das richtige Passwort zu haben.
Aber diese Backdoor funktioniert aber nicht wirklich,
sondern führt zu Problemen bei einer normalen Anmeldung und ist außerdem in
dem Code von XZ enorm gut versteckt.
Nämlich so, dass sie nicht normal im Code zu finden ist, sondern dann,
wenn man XZ kompiliert, wird aus einem Testcase quasi,
steganografisch etwas rausgeholt und in den Code im Code untergebracht.
Also wirklich gezielt eine Backdoor platziert und der Code, wirklich aus dem
sie besteht, wird nur beim Kompilieren unter bestimmten Bedingungen aus einer,
aus einer Testdatei, wo man die Kompression nämlich mitprüfen soll, wiederhergestellt.
Ein guter Grund, warum da einfach irgendeine Datei ist, die random aussieht.
Wie ist das dahin geraten? Jetzt kommen wir also von dem anderen Ende.
Er deckt jetzt diese krasse Backdoor.
Und jetzt kommen wir zum anderen Ende. Was war denn in diesem XZ-Projekt los?
Und da kommen wir zu dem Teil, der glaube ich hier für Logbuch-Netzpolitik viel
interessanter ist. Es gibt ja,
Die Open-Source-Community. Die stereotype Vorstellung davon ist,
dass das alles so ein paar Hippies mit Pferdedecke und Wollsocken sind, die an ihrem,
Computer sitzen und,
Pizza essen, Mate trinken und der Welt diese tolle Software frei und kostenlos
zur Verfügung stellen und nächstes Jahr da gibt es Linux on the Desktop.
Das ist so die Außenperspektive. Und dann gibt es immer noch Leute,
die sagen, ja, und weil das ja alles Open Source ist, können ja alle den Quellcode einsehen.
Und deswegen ist das sicherer, weil das ja alle machen. Also irgendjemand wird
sich das ja schon angucken.
Ich glaube, die Realität ist ein bisschen eine andere. Solche Software-Libraries
werden gepflegt teilweise von, Die Developern im Ehrenamt, das ist durchaus
jetzt nicht auszuschließen.
Die Maintainer sind aber natürlich häufig Leute, die irgendwie ein Interesse
am Fortbestand dieser Software-Library haben.
Und diejenigen, die dazu contributen, sind auch Leute, die in der Regel eine
Funktionalität hinzufügen möchten,
die die Library auch benutzen, die irgendwann mal darüber stolpern bei ihrer
Nutzung, darin eine Optimierung feststellen oder so.
Und so trifft sich dann diese Entwickler-Community in den Repositories,
hauptsächlich würde ich sagen auf GitHub und sagt dort, ey,
ich habe hier auch noch eine Verbesserung an diesem Code, die ich gerne beitragen möchte.
Und häufig stehen diese Leute irgendwo anders in Lohn und Brot.
Die Leute, die den Linux-Kernel entwickeln oder die Beiträge zum Linux-Kernel
schreiben, was meinst du, wo die arbeiten?
Die arbeiten bei Red Hat, die arbeiten bei Suse, aber die arbeiten natürlich
auch bei Facebook, bei Google, bei Microsoft und sonst wo. Und bei Deutschland. Und bei Deutschland.
GmbH. Und die Funktionalitäten, die sie in den Linux-Körnel reinschreiben,
das sind welche, die sie selber brauchen.
Ist doch klar, die sitzen noch nicht da und sagen, heute schreibe ich mal einen
Treiber für irgendeine Grafikkarte im Linux-Körnel.
Nein, die schreiben den Treiber für ihre Grafikkarte, die sie brauchen.
Das heißt, da sind natürlich, findet diese...
Diese Entwicklung mit kommerziellen Interessen statt. Ist ja klar.
Und getrieben von kommerziellen Interessen. Und bei einigen Tools entsteht natürlich
auch so ein bisschen der Eindruck, dass die potenziell vielleicht auch einfach jetzt mal fertig sind.
So zum Beispiel diese XZ-Library. Der Kompressionsalgorithmus ist nach meinem
Dafürhalten ohnehin jetzt nicht ein enorm verbreiteter.
Gzip ist häufiger verbreitet.
Ich glaube aber nicht notwendigerweise besser, weiß aber jetzt nicht so genau.
Und jetzt hast du da diese XZ-Library. Irgendjemand hat die unliebsame Aufgabe,
das Ding zu maintainen und hat wahrscheinlich in seinem Leben noch eine ganze
Menge anderer Dinge zu tun.
Und jetzt passiert folgendes, da kommen auf einmal total aktive Contributor.
Und die pflegen ein Jahr, machen die die ganze Zeit Contributions zu dem Projekt
und wenn ihre Vorschläge nicht nach kürzester Zeit angenommen und in das Projekt
vom Maintainer integriert wurden,
dann fangen die an sich zu beschweren und am Ende sagen sie dem Maintainer,
ey pass mal auf, du machst doch hier eh nichts mehr,
wie wäre es denn, wenn ich jetzt einfach Maintainer werde?
Und dann sagt der Metaider, hast eigentlich recht, seit zwei Jahren interessiert
mich diese scheiß Software-Library überhaupt nicht mehr.
Ich werde von euch hier die ganze Zeit nur angekackt. Ich sehe auch gar keinen
Sinn darin, das jetzt irgendwie weiter zu pflegen. In meinem Leben zumindest nicht.
Ich habe auch andere Sorgen.
Einen chinesisch klingenden Namen hat, aber sonst eigentlich auch eher aus dem
Nichts kam, wurde dann eben das Maintainership für diese Software-Library übergeben
und danach konnte die Person da schalten und walten, wie sie wollte.
Weil eben genau nicht noch irgendjemand anders drauf schaut,
was ich glaube eine der großen, großen Lebenslügen dieser Open Software, des Open Software,
der Open Software Kontrolle ist, dass man sich die ganze Zeit vorstellt,
da wären irgendwo tausend Augen von irgendwelchen Leuten im Internet,
die den Code lesen und sagen, der ist in Ordnung.
Das passiert in großen Stellen des Codes halt nicht.
Das passiert einfach nicht.
Genau, weil die Motivation, das zu tun, ist natürlich vielfältig.
Und das kommt natürlich auch alles noch aus einer Zeit.
Also Open Source oder Free Software, je nachdem welchen Take man da jetzt drauf
nimmt, ist auch noch was relativ Neues.
Du musst ja Floss sagen. Free as in Libre Open Source Software.
Genau, choose your poison. Auf jeden Fall die kostenlose Bereitstellung von
Source Code Und insbesondere eben das Projekt Linux,
um das sich herum dieses grandiose Ökosystem aufgebaut hat, was ja heutzutage
für viele Computer da draußen wirklich der Standard ist.
Also insbesondere Server. Also man kann immer witzeln über Linux on the Desktop,
ob das nun jetzt kommt oder nicht, ist aber erstmal für den Erfolg dieses Systems
unerheblich, denn den hat es gehabt und hat es noch.
Das ist halt einfach mal so der Standard, wenn du einen Server heute hast,
dann ist der in der Regel, läuft der unter Linux. Es gibt Ausnahmen, aber...
Und selbst dann ist es immer noch so ein Unix-Derivat.
Also eigentlich ist alles, was heutzutage auf Servern läuft,
vielleicht mit der Ausnahme von Microsoft-Servern, ist Unix und dann eben in
den meisten Fällen auch Linux.
Und dazu eben dieses ganze Ökosystem.
So, und wann ist das gestartet? Das ist Anfang der 90er Jahre gestartet.
Das heißt, wir blicken jetzt im Prinzip auf ungefähr 30 Jahre,
die dieses Ökosystem sich entwickelt hat.
Das heißt, die meisten Leute, die das angestoßen haben, die leben auch noch. Ein paar nicht mehr.
Und wir werden natürlich jetzt immer mehr sehen, dass die ursprünglichen Entwickler
es nicht mehr machen können,
versterben, they move on to other things, Dinge passieren, andere Leute übernehmen
und in vielen Fällen wird es auch kein Problem sein, weil der Code, der interessant ist,
ja, also der, was weiß ich, laufend immer wieder neue Herausforderungen hat,
der von vielen Leuten angeschaut wird, So was wie ein Netzwerkkode,
wo sich einfach die ganze Zeit irgendwas ändert, wo man immer auf irgendwas reagieren muss,
wo die Standards sich am laufenden Meter weiterentwickeln, die Anforderungen
durch neue Hardware, Timings, Geschwindigkeiten.
Vereinbarungen, Protokolle und so weiter immer wieder was Neues dazukommt und
wo auch so ein permanenter Verbesserungsbedarf ist.
Da werden nach wie vor viele Leute drauf schauen, das wird heiß diskutiert werden.
Aber so diese langweiligen Sachen, in Anführungsstrichen, oder sagen wir mal
so die fertigen Sachen, der gut abgehangene Code, der aber eben auch da sein
muss, der erfährt eben nicht mehr so diese Aufmerksamkeit.
Und das macht jetzt den Eindruck, dass in diesem Fall das Ganze sozusagen als
eine systemische Sicherheitslücke begriffen wurde, weil man halt gesehen hat,
dass man über dieses Einfallstor dieser Library,
die erstmal völlig harmlos daherkommt, so ja, ich mach Datenkompression, Das,
wie man gesehen hat, die hängt aber jetzt konkret bei modernen Linux-Distributionen
in so einer ganz wichtigen Komponente, diesem System D,
so diesem zentralen Schaltwerk des moderner Linux-Systeme mit drin und kann
eben dann auch über diesen ausgenutzten Pfad tatsächlich in das Verhalten von SSH, also dem Tool.
Was sichere Verbindungen über das Netzwerk letztlich erlaubt, da eingreifen.
Und um dort Veränderungen machen zu können, die dann mehr oder weniger universell
weltweit in allen Systemen ausgerollt worden wären.
Dazu kam es ja letzten Endes nicht mehr, dafür bedurfte es in Anführungsstrichen
nur, diese Maintainership zu übernehmen.
Und diese Person war halt niemandem bekannt,
auch dem anderen Maintainer nicht, sondern das sind alles nur Usernames on the
Internet und es gab ja auch verschiedene Fürsprecher für diesen Entwickler,
die sich dann in dieser Diskussion für den eingesetzt haben,
ob das wirklich reale Personen sind, we don't know.
Kann sein, dass das alles nur von einer einzigen Person gemacht wurde.
Kann natürlich auch sein, wie viele vermutet haben, dass es sich hier um eine
konzertierte Aktion handelt, weil was ja bemerkenswert ist hier,
das ist ja nicht so eine Attacke, die jetzt mal so einen Monat oder so vorangezogen
wurde, sondern das ist ja so ein Plan,
der sich über einen Zeitraum von, ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, so mindestens einem,
vielleicht sogar zwei Jahren abgespielt hat.
Nee, ich hab im Kopf irgendwie zwei, ja.
Ja, ich auch, aber ich hab die Timeline jetzt nicht vor Augen.
Also, ne, dieses ganze Heranpirschen, dieses, ha, hier, guck mal,
hallo, ich hab hier einen Code und so weiter.
Also man hat erstmal Zeit genutzt, um dieses Vertrauen aufzubauen.
Als es dann eben wirklich zum Wechsel dieses Maintainerships kam,
nach zwei Jahren, dann ging's halt rasant.
Und dieser, ähm, die Technik, die dort zum Einsatz kam, die du ja gerade schon
beschrieben hast, die ist jetzt schon,
na, ich weiß nicht, was würde würdest du dem so für ein Advanced-Level zuweisen,
würde ich sagen, ist schon ziemlich advanced.
Also da sind schon so Leute am Start gewesen oder zumindest eine Person am Start
gewesen, die genau wusste, was sie da tut und die nicht nur in der Lage war,
es zu machen, sondern es sozusagen auch noch relativ gut zu verstecken.
Nur halt trotzdem einen Fehler gemacht irgendwo.
29.10.2021 hatte den ersten Patch auf die XZ-Developer-Mailing-List.
Also zweieinhalb Jahre lief diese Operation.
Und die tatsächliche Backdoor wurde, mal gucken,
wurde wahrscheinlich irgendwie so, 23.02.
Hat er die ausgerollt und wir können, also um jetzt mal die andere Perspektive
zu sagen, das ist irre, dass das jemand gefunden hat.
Also das ist haarscharf, also das hätte problemlos durchgehen können,
wenn er da nicht irgendwie einen kleinen Fehler gehabt hätte und wenn die Backdoor
ein bisschen stabiler gewesen wäre.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass die jemand entdeckt, war äußerst gering.
Aber, das muss man nochmal sagen, sie hat es nur in die Unstable-Version,
in die Testing-Version von einigen Linux-Distributionen geschafft,
die niemand, der grob klar denkt, im Produktiveinsatz hat.
Aber der nächste Schritt wäre gewesen, wenn das da stabil läuft,
dann wird irgendwann gesagt, alles klar, die Runde läuft, jetzt machen wir ein
nächstes Update und dann fließt das irgendwann in die Stable-Version.
Und das hätte jetzt, keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht, wie lange das jetzt doch gedauert hätte.
Wahrscheinlich eher ein bisschen länger oder vielleicht auch ein bisschen schneller,
weil keiner denkt, dass das bei der LibLZMA irgendwie eine Rolle spielt.
Aber das wäre früher oder später, wenn das nicht entdeckt worden wäre,
wäre das irgendwann signifikant massenhaft auf Linux und Unix auf Linux-Systemen
primär gewesen und dann hättest du eine Situation gehabt,
in der vermutlich, wer auch immer sich diese Operation ausgedacht hat.
Mit Hilfe dieser Backdoor auf alle Systeme draufgekommen wäre,
die mit dieser Backdoor versehen sind.
Und dann wäre die Frage gewesen, wie klug sich die Angreifenden mit diesem Wissen verhalten.
Ob sie das für Spionagezwecke nutzen, ob sie das für Sabotagezwecke nutzen,
aber so oder so wäre es ein absolutes Desaster gewesen.
Und das krasse ist, dass man sich jetzt natürlich die Frage stellt,
ist das die einzige Sache, wo sie es gemacht haben?
Wäre ja auf andere Weise auch echt schwierig, alle Eier in einen Korb zu legen
und irgendwie über mehrere Jahre ein XZ herum entwickeln zu müssen,
um dann irgendwann da mal so ein Ding reinzuschieben.
Oder ob man sagt, alles klar, wir machen das mal am besten mit fünf,
sechs unterschiedlichen.
Die Pendancies und versuchen mal noch auf anderen Wegen das Ganze zu machen
oder andere Leute hatten die Idee auch und haben es auch gut gemacht.
Ja und jetzt stellt sich natürlich die Frage,
Wie geht man damit um und kann man da eigentlich was gegen tun?
Kurzfristig stellt sich natürlich jetzt vielleicht so die Frage,
okay, ist irgendwo in den letzten zwei Jahren auch so ein Maintainership von
irgendeinem Projekt auf jemand anders übergegangen?
Weiß man das eigentlich?
Wird das irgendwo registriert? Kommt man an die Leute ran, die einem diese Informationen liefern könnten?
Wie kann man jetzt überhaupt den Leuten trauen, also auch den aktuellen Maintainern?
Also woher weiß man denn, dass nicht irgendwie in allen Bibliotheken Malicious
Code schon am Start ist? weil den Leuten vielleicht, ich meine,
in diesem Fall war es ja wirklich ein Wechsel der Personalie.
In einem anderen Fall kann es ja auch einfach sein, dass Leute vielleicht,
ich denke mir jetzt was aus,
ich weiß, ich sage nicht, das ist passiert, aber es ist natürlich auch vorstellbar,
dass einfach Druck ausgeübt wird auf Entwickler, die diesen Maintainer Zugriff haben.
Durch was auch immer, durch Geld, durch Bedrohung, durch keine Ahnung, was auch immer.
Ich meine, wenn genug Geld und Machtgewinn im Spiel ist,
dann ist auf jeden Fall meistens selten Ressourcenmangel bei der Anwendung von
solchen Strategien das Problem.
Und dementsprechend muss man sich halt fragen, wie kann man sich denn dagegen absichern?
Ist sozusagen diese wunderbare Vorstellung von einer Ansammlung von benevolenten
Diktatoren, die sozusagen für diese ganzen Projekte stehen,
ist es wirklich ein belastbares Modell in einer Welt,
in der so viel Sicherheit im Spiel und auf dem Spiel steht beim Einsatz von Computern.
Tja, da wird man sich auf jeden Fall jetzt ein paar Gedanken zu machen.
Ich denke, es gibt natürlich jetzt Überlegungen.
Wie man derartiges Verhalten vielleicht automatisiert detektieren kann,
ob man irgendwelche Tests machen kann.
Entscheidend war hier ja, wenn du wirklich das Ding baust, entsteht auf einmal anderer Code.
Da gibt es also so dieser ganze Ansatz mit reproducible builds.
Reproduzierbare builds.
Also quasi, dass man wirklich einen deterministischen einen kompilierungsprozess hat,
das geht da in eine interessante Richtung wo man nachher sagen kann,
okay da fällt ein Binary raus, das hat einfach diesen Hash und,
den wird es immer haben, egal auf welchem System man das zu welcher Uhrzeit
ausführt das sind denke ich technische Unterstützungen dabei,
derartige Aktivitäten in Zukunft vielleicht auch zu entdecken.
Zumindest eine Abänderung die.
Sozusagen jetzt die Differenz Diese eine Art Aber.
Man weiß ja nicht, ob nicht auch in dem normalen Code schon irgendwie etwas
versteckt ist, weil so genau schaut sich das ja dann am Ende In.
Dem normalen Code sind doch eh Schwachstellen Also die kommen da ja auch ohnehin
rein Das darf man ja auch nicht vergessen Das ist ja einer der Fehler die die
hier gemacht haben, ist, dass dass sie halt wirklich eine richtige Backdoor gebaut haben.
Profis machen eine Backdoor, um plausible deniability zu haben.
Aber ich glaube, also jetzt als jemand, der in der IT-Security-Bereiche auch
arbeitet, glaube ich, jetzt wird Folgendes passieren.
Es wird jetzt eine neue Aufmerksamkeit auf derartiges geben.
Ich würde hoffen, dass wir noch weitere derartige Aktivitäten finden.
Weil ich die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es die einzige ist, halte ich für relativ gering.
Und, also ich sag mal, ich würde mich wohler fühlen, wenn wir noch mehr finden.
Und dann werden wir mal schauen.
Dass so etwas denkbar ist, ist jetzt auch nichts Neues.
Ja, das, vielleicht haben wir da lange, einige Zeit ein bisschen zu naiv drauf
geschaut. Habe ich ja am Anfang auch ein bisschen gemacht.
Übrigens nix gegen Hippies mit Pferdedecken.
Ich wollte da nur das Serotip bemühen, wie man sich das ja so alles vorstellt
mit der freien Software, die die Leute für uns schreiben.
Ich meine, in diesem Fall war halt Open Source betroffen und letzten Endes müssen
sich natürlich auch die Firmen selber, die jetzt sozusagen ihren eigenen Code
haben, natürlich auch ähnliche Fragen stellen.
Ja, aber das wird jetzt nicht, also Open Source zu entwickeln und zu pflegen
hat zu viele Gewinne und Vorteile für alle Beteiligten,
als dass jetzt die Open Source Entwicklung zum Erliegen käme oder so.
Naja, gut. Schauen wir mal was, wo man ein bisschen Abwechslung bekommen kann. TikTok.
Ja, wieder so ein Thema, was ich nicht verfolgt habe. Also,
der.
Vielleicht hast du das mehr verfolgt. Also mein Eindruck ist,
in USA und Europa macht man sich seit längerer Zeit größere Gedanken,
dass TikTok schädlich ist für die Kinder.
Das ist eine. Und außerdem, dass man TikTok nicht trauen kann,
weil das ja aus China kommt.
Da kommen dann so geile Sachen raus wie, Kanzler Scholz ist jetzt auch auf TikTok
und der hat aber ein extra anderes Handy, weil die China-App darf nicht beim Kanzler aufs Handy.
Ist ja auch, ist wahrscheinlich sogar richtig, dass der auf seinem Diensthandy kein TikTok hat, ja.
Da würde ich wirklich sagen, das ist wahrscheinlich ganz gut, ja.
Ja, gleichzeitig kommen jetzt auch gerade wieder die Anfragen,
das ist auch so ein regelmäßiges Ding, also bei presse.ccc.de oder über mein
Kontaktformular kommen,
ich weiß nicht, also kommen immer so in Schüben so, hören die uns ab mit dem Handy?
Ist das Mikrofon an? Wir legen das Handy dahin und dann sagen wir ganz oft,
was weiß ich, Küche, Küche, Küche und dann, wenn dann irgendwann Werbung für
eine fucking Küche kommt, dann sagen wir, ja hier, guck mal,
wie ist denn der Handy, hört uns ab.
Also das kommt jetzt gerade auch alles wieder.
Also, die Spionage-App aus China, die Manipulations-App aus China und was wirft man TikTok noch vor?
Kinder.
Genau, macht die Kinder kaputt. Genau, macht die Kinder kaputt.
Informations-
Attacken zu starten. Hartes Wort jetzt.
Genau. Und die Amis haben es erfunden.
Die machen das mit Facebook und Google und Twitter seit, weiß ich nicht, Jahrzehnten.
Aber jetzt macht die Mese das auch. Und jetzt könnte ja jeder kommen.
Und jetzt wollen sie das verbieten. Also ist die Geschichte damit nicht zu Ende erzählt?
Naja, sie wollen es ja nicht verbieten, sondern sie wollen es ja nur verbieten,
aber wenn es in den USA dann doch noch weiterlaufen soll, dann könnte man es ja auch kaufen.
Sie sagen, das darf hier nur noch in den USA betrieben werden,
wenn wir das kaufen dürfen.
Ja genau, die Republikaner hatten auch schon ein paar Ideen,
wer das so kaufen könnte, als diese ganzen Schergen da von Trump.
Peter Thiel und Elon Musk.
Dieser ehemalige Wirtschaftsminister von Trump, dieser Vollidiot,
ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, wie der heißt.
Auf jeden Fall Weil, ja, also natürlich ist das irgendwie alles so ein bisschen
absurd, aber man kann jetzt auch nicht bestreiten, dass diese Probleme wirklich da sind.
Weil du kannst ja mal versuchen, irgendwas über das Tiananmen-Massaker irgendwie
auf TikTok zu posten, da wirst du nicht so viel Erfolg mit haben.
T-I-L.
T-I-L, genau.
Tiananmen.
Ja, da siehst du es mal, genau.
Genau, für unsere für unsere jüngeren Hörer,
Wann war das?
Oh, 60er Jahre?
Ah nein, das war nicht in den 60er Jahren.
Das war also die Niederschlagung der chinesischen Protestbewegung, das war im Juni 89.
Genau, das war so kurz vor Wende war das hier so der große Aufreger.
Schön, es war zu einer Zeit, zu der ich noch sagen kann, dass ich keine kognitive Fähigkeiten hatte.
Ja siehst du mal, und dann weißt du auch nicht, wie das damals so medial aufgeschlagen
ist und welche Bedeutung das hat und das war halt damals so der große...
Aber du sagst, wenn ich mich jetzt dafür interessiere und das herausfinden will, TikTok ist...
Schlechte Quelle.
Ach nicht gut.
Nee, nicht gut.
Ich dachte das ist K-Maschine.
Naja.
Wenn mich weibliche Brustwarzen interessieren würden, dann wäre Facebook nicht der richtige Ort.
Stimmt. Interessierst du dich für weibliche Brustwarzen?
Meins, ne?
Okay.
Verzicht mir jetzt erstmal nicht weiter. Also was halten wir jetzt davon?
Das ist natürlich jetzt in gewisser Hinsicht eine interessante Krise,
die sich da jetzt zusammenbraut.
Nämlich so bisschen Zauberlehrlings mäßig jetzt haben wir diese ganzen Tools
gebaut und jetzt passen sie uns auf einmal nicht,
weil jetzt irgendwie wehe wehe das Wasser überall entlang flutet und Ärger macht
und jetzt ist es auf einmal eine Frage der nationalen Sicherheit, weil man halt in einem.
Fernduell mit China sich wähnt,
Und geopolitische Spannungen um Taiwan eine Rolle spielen und natürlich auch
sehr viel im Bereich der Wirtschaftsspionage.
Aber eben in zunehmendem Maße auch das Bedenken, dass ebenso wie es die Russen
nun schon lange Zeit machen, auch die Chinesen über diese Werkzeuge die öffentliche
Meinung im Westen beeinflussen können.
Und das sicherlich auf die eine oder andere Art und Weise auch schon tun und
sei es erstmal durch das Weglassen von Informationen.
Genauso eignen sich aber nun diese Netzwerke auch, indem man den Algorithmus
entsprechend anpasst, indem man bestimmte Informationen pusht.
Und auch China ist mittlerweile bekannt als Quelle von Desinformation.
Nicht nur auf TikTok, aber eben auch auf TikTok,
wann auch immer irgendetwas passiert mittlerweile auf dieser Welt,
irgendwo ein Terroranschlag oder
irgendwie ein Unglück, was dann aber als Terroranschlag gepostet wird.
Und dann siehst du halt auf einmal so Fliegen innerhalb kürzester Zeit,
tausend Videos und Takes auf diese Sache und was da jetzt wieder sein kann und
wer dann dahinter steht.
Das ist halt einfach so die Methode der informationellen Kriegsführung,
wie man sie auch eben von den Russen sehr stark sieht.
Und dieses Gesamtgeschehen, das sorgt jetzt eben im amerikanischen Kongress
für diese Entscheidung, dass man jetzt irgendwie TikTok untersagen will.
Und jetzt haben wir natürlich so ein bisschen das Problem, wie bewerten wir
denn das, weil so das komplette Abschalten von irgendwelchen Netzwerken ist
natürlich auch problematisch.
Ja, also ich,
Also das Einzige, was mir daran nicht gefällt an dieser ganzen Debatte,
ist dieser dann doch irgendwie so zu tun, als würde Facebook mit Instagram das nicht tun.
Also ich weiß ja, ob TikTok jetzt so viel besser ist.
Ich habe das irgendwann vor ein paar Jahren mal ausprobiert und ich kann mit
diesem Zeitsenken nicht so viel anfangen.
Aber andere Leute tun das.
Genau, andere Leute tun das und das ist sicherlich alles.
Wir hatten jetzt hier gerade diesen russischen Spion irgendwie bei der Bundeswehr,
der jetzt irgendwie aufgedeckt wurde, der meinte so, ja er hat sich irgendwie auf TikTok,
auf Deeps Videos angeschaut und ist dann dadurch umgestimmt worden und hat sich
dann bemüht den Russen irgendwie geheime Informationen zukommen zu lassen.
Ja, gut. Also natürlich ist es relevant, wo Menschen ihre Aufmerksamkeit haben
und was ihnen da präsentiert wird.
Das ist unglaubliche Macht- und Einflussmaschinen.
Ganz ohne Frage, ist so.
Aber ich kann nicht sagen, dass die Macht- und Einflussmaschine Facebook oder
Instagram irgendwie weniger gefährlich wäre.
Nö.
Aber es gibt dann Potenzial, dass man sagt, okay, wenn wir Glück haben,
also an Twitter kann man sehen, welchen Einfluss ein völlig Irrer an der Spitze
eines solchen Unternehmens hat.
Da kann man ja wirklich mal sehr schön sehen, wie so ein Ding kippen kann,
wenn da jemand mal wirklich anders möchte.
Also das ist glaube ich ein sehr schönes Beispiel dafür, wie stark das Ding
doch dann beeinflussbar ist.
Die Manipulation, die das irgendwie ein Mensch davor ruft.
Aber ich würde es nochmal gerne benennen, wenn diese Systeme die ganze Zeit
sind, die dafür da, oder die werden damit finanziert, dass man Dinge kauft.
Dieses, ich glaube ich habe das mal erzählt, dass ich irgendwie auf Instagram
einmal auf so eine Küchenanzeige geklickt habe.
Seit Jahren, wenn ich Instagram aufmache, kann ich nur noch Küchen angucken.
Also ich muss jetzt irgendwann mal eine Küche kaufen, damit das aufhört.
Aber diese Trennung, das sind Aufmerksamkeitsmagnete zum Zwecke der Verhaltensmanipulation,
nämlich kauf irgendeinen Shit.
Und solange wir das nur für Produkte haben oder so, finden wir es völlig in Ordnung.
Und niemand beschwert sich darüber, dass die Dinger damit finanziert werden
und dafür da sind und unsere Kommunikationswünsche ausnutzen und monetarisieren
und sammeln und auswerten,
nur um uns irgendeine Scheiße zu verkaufen.
Ich schon, ich beschwöre mich da schon immer drüber.
Du gibst denen dann Geld dafür, dass die Werbung weg ist. Übrigens,
bald hat Google mich auch so weiten will, als wir gerade versucht haben.
Wenn es die Option gibt, man kann ja auch immer noch auf Entzug leben,
aber ja, ich will keine Werbung.
Am Ende haben beide das gleiche gebaut und ich finde, im Zweifelsfall ist diese
Maschine einfach insgesamt schlecht.
Und was ich unschön finde, ist, dass dann gesagt wird, hier,
das ist aber jetzt vom Chinesen und deswegen wollen wir das nicht.
Und das gleiche Ansatz in Grün, noch viel, viel mächtiger,
noch viel, viel mehr Nutzerinnen, noch viel, viel verbreiteter aktuell noch
im westlichen Bereich vom Amerikaner, das benutzen wir. Das finden wir in Ordnung.
Und das ist so dieser Teil, der mir da, ich komme nicht so in diese Block und
System, denke da ist der Böse, da ist der Feind, da komme ich nicht so ganz rein.
Ja, naja gut. Also ich meine China macht das ja nun schon länger und gibt den
Unternehmen halt dann sehr klare Dinge vor.
Wenn ihr hier noch in irgendeiner Form tätig sein wollt, dann müsst ihr halt das und das machen.
Das gilt halt für Investitionen, dass da irgendwie chinesische Unternehmen beteiligt
sein müssen an den Firmen, die sich in China niederlassen.
Und es gilt natürlich dann auch für, wo sind die Daten gespeichert,
also wenn ihr da irgendwie was in die Cloud schreiben wollt,
dann muss die Cloud aber auch in China stehen und da passieren dann andere Dinge,
als wenn die Server in den USA stehen und viele westliche Unternehmen lassen sich darauf ja auch ein.
Und natürlich ist das sozusagen so ein bisschen off-concern und der Westen kommt
jetzt sozusagen auch in diesen, ob es den Geschmack oder sieht sich dazu gezwungen,
Einflussnahme von außen einzuschränken oder im Idealfall sogar zu verhindern,
indem man Strukturen schafft, wo man eben Druck auf diese Unternehmen ausüben kann.
So, also das ist ja eigentlich auch so eine Aussage. Ich meine,
dass man das jetzt so über Ownership macht, finde ich ja ganz interessant.
Das ist jetzt so ein neuer Spin.
Es gibt noch eine andere Perspektive, die man zumindest unterstellen kann,
die zumindest naheliegend ist.
Und das ist einfach Wirtschaftsprotektionismus.
Also.
Ja, na gut, ich meine, das würde ja dann implizieren, dass jetzt TikTok sozusagen
eine große wirtschaftliche Gefahr darstellt.
Das sehe ich jetzt nicht. Das ist zwar sicherlich nicht unerfolgreich.
Also im Gegensatz zu Instagram wächst das, ne?
Ja gut, aber solche Dinge können sich dann halt auch wieder ändern.
Das ist jetzt aber nicht so, dass jetzt die amerikanische Wirtschaft droht den
Bach runter zu gehen, weil TikTok erfolgreich ist.
Ja, aber Wirtschaftsprotektionismus musst du auch früher machen.
Ja, also meine Wahrnehmung ist, dass es eher unter Sicherheits- und Kontrollaspekten
jetzt zu dieser Entscheidung kam und nicht so sehr unter wirtschaftlichen,
weil dann könnte man ja im Zweifelsfall auch irgendwie über Zölle oder sowas reagieren.
Ja, also ich denke, dass das eine unliebsame Konkurrenz ist,
das würde ich nicht von der Hand weisen.
Es hat auch was mit medialer Kontrolle zu tun.
Also es ist immer ein bisschen schwierig mit diesen Zahlen und die,
die ich gehört habe, habe ich jetzt auch nicht mehr so komplett im Kopf.
Aber du kannst mal davon ausgehen, dass mehr Leute über TikTok ihre Nachrichten
wahrnehmen mittlerweile in den USA als jetzt über alle anderen Fernsehsender
CNN und so weiter zusammen.
Das heißt, das ist schon eine extreme Einflussmaschine und während du eben für
die anderen Medienkonzerne in den USA,
da wäre es mal nur bei dieser USA-Perspektive, entsprechende Regeln hast und
Kontrollmechanismen und Bestrafungsmechanismen, die sicherlich nicht weit genug gehen in den USA,
wenn man sich den Medienzirkus dort anschaut, aber zumindest existiert das ja.
Und über das Internet und über solche Systeme kommen halt jetzt sozusagen vollkommen
unkontrollierte Nachrichtenkanäle rein und die sind halt einfach ein Einfallstor
für ungezügelte Disinformationen,
die halt stattfinden kann.
Und mit Disinformationen kennen sie sich halt schon aus, bloß aus China und
aus Russland wollen sie sich das jetzt nicht unbedingt eintreten.
Das ist schon, finde ich, die primäre Motivation für diesen Move,
ob das jetzt die richtige Maßnahme ist.
Keine Ahnung. Also ich bin mir jetzt auch nicht so sicher, wohin hier die Reise
geht, aber das ist zumindest die Auseinandersetzung, die hier stattfindet und
wir werden diese Diskussion sicherlich auch in Europa bald führen.
Jaja, die fängt in Europa jetzt schon an. Europa fängt jetzt an zu sagen,
lass uns mal gucken, ob die gegen irgendwelche EU-Richtlinien verstoßen und so weiter.
Ja ich meine nach dem Kriegsbeginn in der Ukraine,
also der Krieg läuft schon seit 10 Jahren, aber nach der Invasion in der Ukraine
vor zwei Jahren, es hat nicht lang gedauert und dieser Fernsehsender RT ist
sozusagen hier über die lokalen Kanäle nicht mehr empfangbar gewesen.
Also von Kabelnetzen geflogen etc.
Ach ist der weg?
Ja, also sicherlich kriegst du ihn noch von irgendeinem Satelliten,
aber sozusagen ist es aktiv dagegen vorgegangen worden.
Das kannst du aber halt mit diesen sozialen Netzwerken nicht machen.
So und man sieht ja was es mit den Leuten macht.
Wir sehen das Treiben der AfD, wie jetzt in den letzten Wochen aufgedeckt worden
ist, dass viele Politiker hier Geld bezogen haben aus Russland und dass sie
jetzt schon seit längerer Zeit russische Talking Points verbreiten.
Und jetzt war jetzt glaube ich auch noch China bei einem Mitarbeiter im Bundestag
jetzt sozusagen auch noch dazu.
Also das sind nicht irgendwie ein Mitarbeiter, das sind direkte Mitarbeiter
von Maximilian Krah, dem Oberführer, der da auf EU-Ebene antreten will.
Also ey, was für eine... Warum geht es denn nur so scheiß Nachrichten?
Ja, dann lach mal. Lach mal ordentlich mal drüber.
Also über diesen Maximilian Krack kannst du ja nur lachen.
Was ist das für ein blöder Schützenfestsäufer.
Also wirklich ey. Das ist doch wirklich die ärmste Sau.
Ja gut, aber diese ganz ehrlich.
Irgend so ein blöder Fettsack mit so Lappenhaaren, der irgendwelche dummen Scheiß
von sich gibt und dann irgendwie, ich mein, Kennst du dieses Video?
Wahrscheinlich gibt es das auf TikTok, wo der irgendwie sagt,
echte Männer sind rechts.
Der redet einen Scheiß. Und das gucken sich dann irgendwie kleine Jungs an und
sagen, ja genau, die Frau gehört in die Küche.
Also hast du den mal fünf Minuten reden hören?
Natürlich habe ich den nicht fünf Minuten reden hören. Ich höre mir keine AfD an.
Also dieses...
Ja gut, musst du nur Markus Lanz oder Thilo Jung anmachen.
Das mache ich ja auch nicht.
Das sind die ja die ganze Zeit. Aber dieser Kral, das ist ein Idiot vor dem Herrn.
Ja, aber ich meine, das ist ja vollkommen klar, aber das sind ja nützliche Idioten,
weil das sind Idioten, die halt sozusagen machtgeil sind Und die letzten Endes
dem Herrn, der am meisten in sie hinein investiert, dienen.
Und wenn das dann halt eine ausländische Macht ist, dann ist das halt so.
Hauptsache die Kohle stimmt. Das ist das Problem. Und diese Leute ohne Gewissen
und ohne ausreichenden Hang zu dem Grundgesetz sind natürlich Einfallstore.
Aber zurück zu den sozialen Netzwerken, das sind dann eben auch die Werkzeuge,
die hier zum Einsatz kommen und es ist ja nicht nur das, was jetzt die AfD selbst
absondert, sondern es ist eben auch das,
womit das Ganze dann flankiert wird durch die Algorithmen.
Das ist schon ein reales Problem, das muss man jetzt sehen, weil es mischt sich eben mit allem.
Es mischt sich mit diesen absurden Challenges, die da auch nochmal für Probleme
sorgen, aber es mischt sich eben vor allem mit gezielter Desinformation.
Und ich meine, dass Leute was falsch wahrnehmen und falsch berichten, das ist so das eine,
aber dass man eben diese Systeme benutzt, um wirklich gezielt für eine Verunsicherung herbeizuführen,
eine Welt zu schaffen, in der die Leute nichts mehr glauben.
Ich meine wir wundern uns immer warum manche Leute einfach vollkommenen Unsinn glauben.
Das ist halt einfach ein Symptom, resultiert aus einer Bombardierung mit tausend
Sachen, die keinen Sinn ergeben und genau das ist das Ziel dieser Propaganda.
Das ist auch immer die Marschrichtung der Russen.
Du erzählst einfach so viel Quatsch und so viel, du kannst es auch so sehen
und so sehen und so sehen, bis irgendwie gar nichts mehr wahr ist.
Und dann zählt einfach nur noch das Gefühl und das Gefühl, das wird halt einfach
durch Angst geschürt. Du machst einfach für irgendwas Angst und in dem Moment,
wo die Leute Angst haben, regiert die Dummheit.
Ja, aber glaubst du denn ernsthaft, also glaubst du wirklich,
dass den Zugang zu versperren, dass das die Lösung ist? Ich frage mich ganz ehrlich.
Hab ich nicht gesagt. Ich hab nur gesagt, das ist das Problem.
Ja super. Ja, das hast du ja auch benannt. Aber lass uns mal überlegen. es mag ja sogar sein.
Ich wäre grundsätzlich würde ich mich an einem,
würde ich sagen, ich bin da, dass ich nach einer Information,
Kannst du im Zweifelsfall nicht vorenthalten und man sollte sie im Zweifelsfall zugänglich machen.
Also ich glaube nicht an Zensur.
Aber sollte eine Disinformation auch zugänglich gemacht werden?
Ich würde ja jetzt erstmal davon ausgehen, dass man erstmal alles zugänglich
machen kann und sich dann im Zweifelsfall schon das Richtige durchsetzt.
Jetzt wird das Ganze kombiniert mit diesen Aufmerksamkeitssuchtsystemen,
wo eben nicht die Information so nüchtern wie möglich bereitgestellt wird und googlebar ist.
Oder irgendwie irgendein Algorithmus für Relevanz da ist, den dann vielleicht
ein paar Leute versuchen zu gamen, aber am Ende kommt schon irgendwie alles durch.
Sondern wir haben halt jetzt irgendwie diese Suchtmaschine, die außerdem verkürzte
Darstellungen belohnen.
Also, die haben ja unseren kompletten Informationskonsum auch geändert.
Und natürlich erkenne ich, dass das eine äußerst unschöne oder für das menschliche
Gehirn sehr ungünstige Entwicklung ist,
wenn wir unseren Marktplatz der Ideen irgendwie in eine Shopping Mall verwandeln.
Und, aber ich glaube, ich weiß halt nicht, ob wir verbieten,
dass, wenn es die Chinesen machen, die Lösung ist, wenn wir sagen,
wir erlauben es aber Facebook.
Also ich glaube, dass man, ich würde sagen, das Problem ist sogar noch größer.
Also ich würde zum Beispiel sagen, yo,
lass uns TikTok verbieten, machen wir sofort morgen,
Eisenhardt, aber dann lass uns Facebook und Instagram und Twitter direkt mit
verbieten, nur noch Mastodon, dann sind die Leute rucki zucki wieder raus aus dem Internet.
Oder einfach Algorithmus verbieten.
Wie Algorithmus verbieten?
Naja, so algorithmische Timelines verbieten.
Und dann?
Dann folgst du nur noch dem, was du folgen willst. Und du kriegst nichts mehr
von der Seite reingeschoben.
Das ist natürlich so das Prinzip von Werbung.
Werbung muss da auch weg. Das verbieten wir als allererstes.
Das verbieten wir noch heute Abend.
Werbung müsste dann zumindest einer klareren Kontrolle unterliegen. Wo kommt das her?
Wer zahlt dafür? Muss bezahlt werden.
Desinformation kommt ja kostenlos. Wird von dem Algorithmus einfach so reingedrückt. So.
Desinformation lohnt sich nicht als bezahlte Werbung so richtig.
Also in einem bestimmten Maße vielleicht auch noch, aber das ist dann schon
mal eine ganz andere Sache und dann kannst du eben auch sagen, okay, wo kommt es her?
Oder zumindest kannst du dann versuchen, da eine entsprechende,
Nachweisbarkeit zu schaffen. Es ist jetzt so ein bisschen ins Blaue hineingeregelt,
aber das eigentliche Problem ist diese automatische Bespielung durch einen Algorithmus.
Keine Ahnung, ob mir ohne einen Algorithmus die YouTube Homepage noch Spaß machen
würde, aber zumindest würde mir die YouTube Homepage,
die ich kriege, wenn ich nicht eingeloggt bin, mehr Spaß machen.
Das ist schon irgendwie alles ganz schlimm.
Also klar, es ist ein Spannungsfeld. Ich sage auch nicht, ich habe jetzt hier die Lösung,
aber es ist auch klar, dass wir es jetzt hier mit einem Problem zu tun haben
und bei diesem Problem geht es jetzt nicht nur um,
was mehr verkauft wird oder nicht oder auch nicht nur um die Sicherheit unserer
Kinder, sondern es geht halt unter Umständen auch um alles.
Um alles?
Naja, Krieg und Frieden und so.
Also ich glaube, da bist du jetzt ein bisschen zu verbissen.
Ich glaube, es geht nur um lustige TikTok-Videos.
Ja, also würdest du sagen, also du hast jetzt das Problem geschildert,
anerkannt, wir sind uns über das Problem einig.
Wir sind uns auch darüber einig, dass das Ausmaß des Problems wahrscheinlich
noch größer ist. So, TikTok-Verbot, ja oder nein?
In den USA?
Ne, also findest du das gut oder nicht?
Was genau finde ich jetzt gut? TikTok? Ja, bist du für ein TikTok-Verbot?
Also mir würde ja im Leben nichts fehlen, wenn es TikTok nicht gäbe,
von daher kann ich das relativ leicht sagen.
Dann können wir auch das Gras von mir aus wieder verbieten.
Es muss an dieser Algorithmus-Sache irgendwas getan werden.
Es muss Auflagen dafür geben.
Und wenn die nicht erfüllt sind, dann darfst du so einen Dienst ja auch nicht haben.
Also du willst Algorithmen besser regulieren.
Es muss also auf jeden Fall eine Verantwortlichkeit geben, wenn du in Deutschland
erreichbar sein willst.
Und da kommen wir natürlich gleich wieder in den nächsten Problembereich rein,
nämlich der Sperren. Also dass du eben wirklich diskutieren musst,
ob Dienste nicht erreichbar sein können in einem Land.
Das ist ja sozusagen die Konsequenz daraus, weil wenn die dann trotzdem da sind
und drauf scheißen, wie wir das hier so rechtlich sehen,
dann hat man ja sozusagen überhaupt gar kein Druckmittel.
Also den USA ist also das US TikTok erfüllt diese Anforderungen.
Welche Anforderungen?
Ähm,
Das 60% von TikTok sind schon in US-amerikanischer Hand mit Sitz in einem Steuerparadies,
aber die Kontrollrechte sind in chinesischer Hand.
Alright. wir sind uns einig, das Problem ist auf jeden Fall noch ein bisschen größer als TikTok.
Okay, super. Dann haben wir noch so einen gemeinsamen Boden gefunden.
Ich weiß halt nicht, also ich würde lieber diese ganzen sozialen Netzwerke verbieten als nur eins.
Klar, aber wir müssen also die generelle Sache ist, können diese medialen Netze
auch eine Waffe gegen diese Gesellschaft sein? Nein, und das zeichnet sich meiner Meinung nach ab.
Und das können wir nicht einfach ignorieren. Da müssen wir schon drüber diskutieren
und auch eine Lösung finden.
Vielleicht ist ja die Bezahlkarte eine Lösung.
Das habe ich mir auch gerade gedacht. Das scheint doch so eine tolle Lösung
zu sein, so ein universeller Zauberstab, den man einfach so einmal von links
nach rechts durch die Luft und dann kleine Sparks.
Es ist einfach nur ein also das ist auch wieder so ein Thema,
was ich nicht so mitbekommen habe.
Aber wenn ich das richtig zusammenfasse, also was ich da jetzt so gehört habe,
ist Asylsuchende, geflüchtete Menschen in Deutschland oder auch auf dauerhaften
Aufenthaltsstatus wartende,
die finanzielle Unterstützung vom deutschen Staat bekommen,
sollen die nicht mehr Bar bekommen.
Die sollen kein Bargeld mehr kriegen. Aktuell kriegen die Bargeld und dann können
die mit dem Bargeld Dinge kaufen.
Und jetzt sollen die eine Karte kriegen. Denkt man sich erstmal?
Interessant, weil man ja Karten in Deutschland eigentlich immer noch nicht so
ein anerkanntes Zahlungsmittel sind.
Aber das bessert sich ja so ein bisschen. Jetzt sollen die mit einer Karte zahlen.
Auf den ersten Blick denke ich, naja, okay, warum nicht?
Und dann wird aber gesagt, ja, bei der Karte, also wollen wir ein bisschen kontrollieren,
mit der Karte sollen die kein Bargeld abheben können,
und mit der Karte können die nicht im Ausland zahlen und wir können da so potenziell
mal so ein bisschen Kontrolle darüber darüber einnehmen, wo die ihr Geld so ausgeben.
Und dann denkst du dir, okay,
warum brauchen wir das denn? Und als Begründung wird dann angeführt,
ja, sonst schicken die Geld zurück an die Schleuser.
Und du denkst dir so, hä? Also was ist das?
Also wer das eine solche Argumentation vorträgt, der gehört doch sofort weggeschickt,
wie kommt man denn mit so einem Quatsch weiter weißt du, die Schleuser,
klar, die sagen pass auf, Jungs,
ihr wollt in ein anderes Land,
ihr wollt in ein anderes Land auf einem anderen Kontinent, kein Problem ich bring euch da hin,
ich bring euch in ein anderes Land und.
Dann stottert ihr das ab.
Ja, dann macht ihr am besten mit Bargeld Geld.
20 Euro pro Monat für die nächsten 30 Jahre.
Weißt du was, ey, wer kann denn so einen Scheiß reden?
Und vor allem, weißt du, dir gibt doch jemand, der dich ins Ausland bringt, ne?
Jemand, der dich ins Ausland schleust, der nimmt doch kein Kredit,
der gibt dir doch keinen Kredit.
Der ist doch nicht bescheuert. Der lässt dir das Geld doch selbstverständlich
vorhergeben. und mal ganz ehrlich, also eins kann ich dir sagen,
Tim, also würden Schleuser,
Kredite anbieten, ne? Also eine Sache würde ich dir sagen, auf jeden Fall werden,
noch ein bisschen mehr Leute hier. Ja?
Weil einer der limitierten Faktoren, warum die nicht hier hinkommen ist,
das Geld, was die nicht haben.
Ja, und wenn da jetzt irgendwie so die deutsche, was weiß ich,
die deutsche Pfandbriefbank sagt so, Schleuserkredit.
Was für ein Scheiß! Was für ein Ein Scheiß!
Ehrlich, wie kann man denn so einen Scheiß reden?
Na, kann ich dir sagen. Das ist einfach. Das ist ein Scheiß-Argument.
Aber wir bedienen rassistisches Rassentiment. Deswegen sagt Alia Woll.
Genau, und vor allem, du könntest ja dann, also die Alternative wäre ja dazu,
den richtigen Grund zu nennen. Der ist aber nicht so geil.
Für das Framing.
Weil, wenn da wirklich Geld verschickt wird, dann bestimmt nicht an Schleuser,
sondern an die Familie in der Heimat, die auch noch Unterstützung braucht und
die gerade nicht geflüchtet ist.
Aber es macht sich halt nicht so geil, wenn du jetzt sagst, die wollen ja nur ihrer Familie helfen.
Ey, das ist so bescheuert. Und ey, also ich.
Und vor allem, dass Bargeld das Problem sein soll.
Also wenn Bargeld ein Problem ist, dann hat Deutschland ein ganz anderes Problem.
Also, Also ein Argument verstehe ich ja, nämlich dieses, dass diese Behörden
selber kein Bargeld mehr ausgeben sollen, weil natürlich die Ausgabe von Bargeld
ein erhöhter Aufwand ist. Da bin ich ja voll dabei.
Insofern ist es auch überhaupt gar kein Problem, den Leuten so eine Karte bereitzustellen.
Das könnte denen auch ein Konto geben.
Da müssen sie ja dann zwangsläufig haben.
Naja, also sie haben ja dann quasi ein Konto.
Sie haben ja dann ein Konto, was sie nicht überziehen können,
was von der Behörde mit dem Geld bestückt wird.
Und eine Karte, mit der sie am Geldautomaten kein Bargeld bekommen.
Genau, das ist halt das Ding. Aber man darf halt damit bezahlen,
aber man darf sich damit kein Bargeld geben lassen.
Was natürlich in Deutschland besonders albern ist, weil du natürlich hier in
vielen Orten nur mit Bargeld überhaupt vorankommst.
Das heißt, du wirst ja dann von der Teilhabe an der Gesellschaft nochmal weiter
ausgeschlossen als ohnehin schon als Asylbewerber.
Aber diese Vorstellung, dass das Abheben von Geld dazu führen würde,
dass dann Schleuser oder eben dann vielleicht auch nur die Familie bezahlt wird,
das scheitert ja schon daran,
wenn du dir anschaust, wie wenig Geld die Leute überhaupt bekommen.
Also wenn die sozusagen überhaupt damit durchkommen wollen und ein halbwegs nachvollziehbares,
würdiges Leben hier leben, was ohnehin schwierig ist unter diesen Bedingungen,
weil die kommen ja hierher, sind teilweise hoch ausgebildet und dürfen nicht arbeiten.
Ja, und wenn dann nur irgendwelche niederen Tätigkeiten, da bleibt ohnehin nicht viel Geld übrig.
Das Geld, was da übrig bleibt, reicht bestimmt nicht für Schleuser.
Also, wirklich, was für ein Quatsch. Und ich glaube, man löst damit kein Problem
und man schafft eine ganze Menge Neuer.
Inklusive Grundrechtseinschränkungen. Ich meine, die wollen den Einsatzbereich
auf Postleitzahlenbereiche eingrenzen.
Das wird bestimmt auch total super funktionieren, wenn dann die Abrechnungssysteme
in anderen Städten sind.
Du kannst das Konto aber wiederum zum Beispiel nicht mit Paypal verbinden,
um irgendwo anders, also das ist wirklich,
es ist richtig Quatsch, ja, also das ist eine richtig dumme Idee und ich bin
jetzt noch nicht mal ein Verfechter von vollkommener Nichtüberwachung finanzieller Ströme,
dafür haben wir genug kriminelle, wo man das anschauen muss.
Aber das ist doch wirklich, also du gängelst irgendwie die Schwächsten,
die in deiner Gesellschaft noch Zuflucht suchen.
Und was wir teilweise für Potenziale ja auch haben, die aus anderen Ländern
zu uns kommen, die dann hier am langen Abend versauern, weil ihnen keine Chance geboten wird.
Weil sie dann, da haben sie irgendwie eine Ausbildung gemacht,
haben jemanden, der sie übernehmen will, alles gut,
ja in irgendeinem Job, für den sich jeder deutsche Internet-Nörgler zu schade
ist, nämlich morgens früh aufstehen und Brötchen backen ja.
Da gibt's ja Leute, die sagen, den Job mach ich ist voll geil,
mach ich, möchte ich machen, hab ich gelernt ich hab die Ausbildung und dann
wird gesagt, nee, du wirst jetzt abgeschoben du nimmst ja sonst hier einen von
unseren Sofa nörgeln, Arbeitsplatz weg oder was.
Also das ist so bescheuert. Das ist so dumm.
Und dann sagst du, pass auf. Und übrigens, jetzt versäuern wir dir das Leben
noch damit, dass du irgendwie eine blöde Karte kriegst, wo wir kontrollieren,
wofür du die paar hundert Euro ausgibst, die wir dir geben.
Ja, ist einfach lächerlich und schämt sich dafür.
Ja, man schämt sich dafür. Vor allem, weil es wirklich einfach nur aus aus irgendeinem
Rassismus getrieben ist, aus irgendeiner dummen Idee.
Es gibt so viele große Probleme, die man lösen kann und was der Scheiß wieder kostet.
Das ist das nächste große Digitalprojekt, was Deutschland dann gegen die Warenfragen kann.
Weißt du, dann hast du irgendwann so eine Karte, wo wenn die bei Null ist,
dann fängt die wieder oben bei Tausend an.
Und, ja, die werden das auch noch verkacken.
Aber nee, weißt du was, die werden es viel geiler verkacken.
Die werden es auf eine Weise verkacken, Dass du irgendwie so regelmäßig dann
alle mit so einer Scheißkarte auf einmal nicht mehr bezahlen können.
Und dann stehen die im Supermarkt und das Ding macht Piep und die können ihre
Fanta-Dose nicht bezahlen oder was sie sich gerade kaufen möchten von ihrem von dem ganzen Geld.
Ja? Und dann steht der Deutsche an der Kasse Ha, hast du wieder alles ausgegeben
am Anfang des Monats, ne?
Das ist doch alles Scheiße.
Alter.
Also wir sind dann nicht dafür.
Nee, das ist einfach nur dumm. Ich fände es schön, wenn die mal was Sinnvolles machen würden.
Komm, lass uns mal schauen, was wir hier bei Logbuch Netzpolitik überhaupt für
Kriminelle in der Sendung haben.
Ja, ein wunderschönes Foto von Thomas, veröffentlicht bei Netzpolitik.org mit Sonnenbrille.
Da sieht er aus, als würde er
in Crooks mitspielen. Denn diese Serie auf Netflix, hast du die geguckt?
Die ist gut, die kannst du mal gucken. Das war wirklich unterhaltsam.
Spielt der mit? Der spielt mit?
Nein, spielt nicht mit, aber der sieht so aus wie einer der Charakter,
also könnte ein Charakter aus dieser Serie sein.
Auf jeden Fall.
Wir haben auch darüber berichtet, dass es in Österreich das epidemiologische Meldesystem,
gab oder immer noch gibt, ich glaube, die melden auch andere Epidemien da drin,
Das hat besondere Relevanz erlangt hier, Today I Learned, 2020 ist eine Pandemie,
hat den Planeten heimgesucht.
Wirklich?
Ja.
Den ganzen?
Fast, ja. Ich glaube es gab so zwei, drei Völker auf Inseln.
Die… Haben nix mitgekriegt.
Weiß man nicht, vielleicht haben sie es nicht. Und da hat das epidemiologische
Meldesystem eine Rolle gespielt.
Da wurden Corona-Daten drin erfasst und da wurden so Zertifikate relativ lax
verteilt, die irgendwie in allen möglichen Händen waren.
Da waren 225 von im Umlauf und eins davon lief auf eine Laborfirma,
die schon gar nicht mehr hätte zugreifen dürfen.
Die konnte aber noch zugreifen und so konnte man mit diesen Zertifikaten wäre es möglich gewesen,
erstens die personenbezogenen Daten, die in diesem System sind,
abzufragen, falsche Laborergebnisse einzuspielen und weil eben diese Zertifikate
nicht personalisiert waren.
Das hatte Epicenter gefunden, also Thomas und seine Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und haben das zusammen mit dem
Standard aufgedeckt und dann auch an das Gesundheitsministerium gemeldet,
bevor sie es veröffentlicht haben und so weiter und so fort.
Die Schwachstelle wurde behoben und dann haben aber Beamte aus dem Gesundheitsministerium
Anzeige nach Paragraf 118 StGB, Achtung, österreichisches StGB,
widerrechtlicher Zugriff auf ein Computersystem gestellt.
Das wurde dann Thomas ein Jahr später mitgeteilt und jetzt dann ein weiteres
Jahr später wurde dieses Verfahren eingestellt.
Jetzt ist natürlich wieder klar, da gehst du als Datenschutz-NGO hin,
meldest eine Sicherheitslücke in einem epidemiologischen Meldesystem an das
Gesundheitsministerium.
Und dann wirst du, dann läuft da zwei Jahre ein Ermittlungsverfahren gegen dich.
Das zeigt natürlich einfach nur, wie völlig bescheuert diese Vorgehensweise
hier ist und dass das Verfahren so lange aufrechterhalten wurde,
lag hoffentlich einfach mal daran,
dass es sich so wenig darum gekümmert wurde, dass es noch nicht mal abgeschlossen wurde.
Das wäre jetzt meine Hoffnung, ja. Natürlich ist das mal wieder eines der immer wieder auftretenden,
dennoch seltenen Beispiele von Hackerparagraphen gegen gute.
Benevolente Hacker. Ich möchte nur an dieser Stelle nochmal sagen,
weil wir immer mehr so beim CCC Meldungen kriegen,
yo ich hab hier was gefunden, meldet ihr das mal, ich hab keinen Bock verklagt zu werden.
Und das ist, ich möchte nochmal dazu sagen, das ist äußerst,
äußerst, äußerst selten, dass so etwas passiert.
Und das ist nichts, wovor man Angst haben muss.
Und ich weiß nicht, wie viele Sicherheitslücken ich schon gemeldet habe.
Und es war noch nie jemand so blöd, mich dafür wirklich anzuzeigen oder zu verklagen
oder Ermittlungen angehen zu lassen.
Man hört natürlich von den Fällen, weil wir die hier behandeln,
weil wir hier auf einen Missstand hinweisen.
Aber in den...
Und es ist einfach äußerst unwahrscheinlich, dass einem so etwas passiert und
auch in diesem Fall jetzt nicht mit wirklich negativen Konsequenzen.
Ja, da wurde jetzt niemand bestraft oder so.
Natürlich ist das nervig, ja, aber.
Aber es gab negative Konsequenzen, das hat die irgendwie 15.000 Euro gekostet,
die nicht vollständig jetzt von Rechtsschutz abgedeckt waren und das ist natürlich
auch Zeit und Aufwand und Nerv und du hast jetzt irgendwie auch keinen Bock
und das ist jetzt sagen wir mal auch für so jemanden wie Thomas,
der zwar sagen wir mal eine dicke Haut hat, sieht man auch auf dem Foto,
Lederjacke und so, also kann auf jeden Fall einiges ab.
Aber trotzdem, ich meine, das ist jetzt nicht so das beste Gefühl,
was du hast, wenn du weißt, der Staat hängt jetzt hier gerade mal so eine Anzeige
hinten an dich dran als Tech, wo du auch mal drei Jahre für einen Knast kommen kannst.
Ja, das stimmt, aber die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist halt äußerst gering.
Ja gut, aber trotzdem hast du es halt an der Backe.
Ja, das ist richtig, aber du kannst auch, also weißt du, man muss ja schon,
also die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist dennoch so gering, dass sie dich nicht davon
abhalten sollte, eine solche Meldung zu machen.
Weißt du, darauf will ich ja hinaus.
Genau das Verhalten, das der gesamtgesellschaftlichen Sicherheit und der demokratischen
Debatte über realistische Bedrohungsszenarien dienen würde, wird durch die aktuelle
Lage, also unter Umständen bestraft.
Beziehungsweise durch das hohe rechtliche Risiko und den enormen Aufwand zumindest
der Untertitel. Das ist alles absolut richtig, natürlich.
Also ich schließe mich dem ja völlig an. Ich möchte nur sagen,
lasst euch bitte nicht davon ermutigen, die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass einem so etwas passiert, ist trotzdem enorm niedrig.
Ja, man hört nur halt von diesen Fällen, weil wir die hier behandeln.
Naja.
So, und Neub hat ein neues Betätigungsfeld, None of Your Business,
wir sind ja gerade bei unseren Ösi-Freunden, Max Schrems, die haben gesagt,
ChatGPT soll aufhören zu lügen.
Und das ist natürlich auch ich meine, die legen natürlich auch den ich meine,
also die sagen,
Also folgendes ist die Argumentation, die sie vortragen. Sie sagen so,
in der EU verlangt die DSGVO, die GDPR,
dass Informationen über Individuen, über Einzelpersonen akkurat ist,
dass sie vollen Zugriff haben auf die Information, die gespeichert wird und
auch die Informationen über die Quelle.
Ja und das ist jetzt, also das ist dieses klassische Ding, wenn ich mit einem
Unternehmen in Kontakt bin oder so, die Daten über mich gespeichert haben,
kann ich sagen, ich hätte gerne alle Daten, die ihr über mich habt und ich hätte
gerne, ich würde gerne wissen, woher ihr die habt.
Und ich kann dann auch sagen, löscht die bitte.
DSGVO, Auskunftsersuchen, Löschungsersuchen und so weiter, alles rechtlich geregelt.
OpenAI sagt, dass sie nicht in der Lage sind, inkorrekte Informationen bei ChatGPT
zu korrigieren, geschweige denn zu entfernen.
Außerdem stimmt auch und sie sagen dass sie,
also das englische Zitat hier ist hier Factual accuracy in large language models
remains an area of active research also Faktengenauigkeit und Faktentreue in
solchen Modellen ist ein Bereich der aktiven Forschung,
und jetzt Jetzt gehen die Neubs hin und sagen, naja, okay, dann reichen wir
jetzt Beschwerde ein bei der österreichischen Datenschutzbehörde,
wo es nämlich offenbar hier ein System betrieben wird, ein Computersystem,
das Informationen über Individuen sagt und eben den DSGVO-Anforderungen nicht entspricht.
Und ja, also ich glaube, die haben inhaltlich recht.
Na die Frage ist, betrifft diese Regelung, diese Anwendung eigentlich wirklich?
Also ist das, was ein Large Language Model macht, eine solche Wissensbasis?
Und ich würde das in Zweifel ziehen.
Moment, du fragst die ganze Zeit Chat-GPT für Wissen.
Ja, aber ich erwarte nicht unbedingt,
dass jetzt Fakten, insbesondere nicht einzelne Daten von Personen,
von irgendwelchen Personen in irgendeiner Form richtig sind.
Also es ist ja auch eine Frage, was erwarte ich von diesem System?
Was verspricht mir dieses System auch?
Nein, nein, nein, es geht nicht darum, was dir dieses System verspricht.
Es ist völlig unerheblich, was es dir verspricht.
Wieso?
Für dein Recht unter Datenschutz ist relevant, dass dieses System offensichtlich
Auskunft über persönliche Daten von dir gibt.
Tut es das?
In diesem Fall ist es ja, also es sagt dir Beispiel, es sagt,
es verbreitet potenziell unwahre Informationen, also es verbreitet potenziell
unwahre Informationen.
Du kannst ihm auch nicht sagen, verbreite, hör auf Informationen über Tim Pridloff
zu verbreiten Du kannst ihm auch nicht sagen, sag wo sag wo du das her hast,
und du kannst auch nicht sagen sag mir alles, was du weißt,
und das sind, das heißt dieser komplette Bereich der DSGVO,
ist, und das ist nun mal gesetzliche Rechte, die du hast nicht,
was du von dem System erwartest sondern Rechte, die du hast bei jedem Unternehmen, was Daten,
von dir verarbeitet und zugänglich macht für andere, oder auch nicht für andere zugänglich macht.
Ja, aber es verarbeitet ja gar nicht die Daten von mir.
Natürlich hat sie die Daten verarbeitet woher weiß es denn sonst.
Wann du Geburtstag hast Ich habe doch da gar keine Daten abgelegt.
Es hat öffentliche Daten von mir.
Ja, das stimmt, aber auch dann hast du diese Auskunftsrechte.
Also wenn jetzt ein Geburtsdatum, was in der Wikipedia steht,
von jemand anderem wiedergegeben wird, dann ist das falsch?
Ja, aber wir haben ja zum Beispiel hier auch schon Fälle behandelt,
wo Leute aufgrund von Persönlichkeitsrechten Google-Ergebnisse gelöscht haben,
weil sie gesagt haben, Google verarbeitet Daten über mich unter einem Suchbegriff.
Also hat Google ein Profil von mir und da habe ich Einsichtsrechte,
Auskunftsrechte und Löschungsrechte.
Und dann haben die Google-Treffer zu ihrem Namen.
Das ist ja der Hinweis, wenn eine Person googelt, steht da, wir geben die Ergebnisse zu einer Person.
Es kann sein, dass diese Ergebnisse von der Person beeinflusst sind.
Ja, also auch Google, sogar Google kannst du untersagen, unter bestimmten Voraussetzungen
bestimmte Ergebnisse zu dir zu liefern. Insbesondere dann, wenn die falsch sind.
Ja, das geht, weil Google sozusagen ein Profil auch von einer Person hat.
Zunächst einmal ist das, also, dass es nicht geht, brauchen wir nicht zu diskutieren.
Das wissen wir ja, dass es nicht geht.
Die Frage ist, was sagt das Gesetz?
Und das Gesetz sagt nicht wenn Google ein Profil hat, darfst du es beeinflussen
oder nicht, sondern das Gesetz sagt,
du hast diese Auskunfts- und sonstigen Rechte und ChatGPT oder OpenAI kann dir die nicht,
einräumen.
Und was machen wir da jetzt? Abschalten, alles abschalten.
Nee, das auch nicht. Aber dass es hier ein Problem gibt, ist glaube ich schon klar.
Ja, das Problem ist bei OpenAI,
ganz unabhängig vom Datenschutz, ähnlich gelagert wie schon diese ganzen Debatten um,
wessen Kunst wird jetzt hier verwendet, gibt es hier sozusagen Copyright-Bedenken,
also alle Einschränkungen,
die auf diese Large Language Models bisher schon gemacht wurden,
Sei es freiwillige Maßnahmen von OpenAI oder eben auch schon in einer Form gesetzliche
Verhinderung oder was weiß ich, militärische Bedenken,
alles mögliche, ja, wird ja dann sozusagen in diese Systemprompts eingebaut.
Verhindere, darüber zu reden wenn ich jetzt irgendwie anfange mach mir ein.
Drehbuch für einen Film, was
so ist wie Bambi von Disney dann wird dir das Ding irgendwie sagen, ja,
so konkret und so weiter kann ich das jetzt aber nicht machen also solche ablehnenden
Sachen gibt es, es gibt sozusagen,
Einflussnamen, aber die können halt auch immer wieder umgangen werden,
indem man halt klüger fragt oder,
dem System einredet, dass es solche.
Regeln nicht begrenzen soll.
Das Problem hier ist, ja, das kann sein, dass diese Systeme das ausspucken und
dieses Regelwerk ist aber eigentlich nicht für diese AI gemacht gewesen.
Sondern die geht ja sozusagen davon aus, dass das sozusagen eine bewusste Informationslieferung
ist und eine konkrete Informationsspeicherung auch ist.
Selbst wenn es eben Suchmaschinen betrifft. Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020,
Und jetzt haben wir eben ein anderes Problem, dass diese Systeme ja das Internet
ja gar nicht literally abspeichern, sondern sich quasi neu ausdenken.
Die lesen das Internet einmal durch und legen so ihre Wahrnehmung in Binärcode
ab und wenn man sie dann befragt,
dann lesen sie diese Interpretation des Internets wieder aus und liefern dann irgendein Ergebnis,
was in den meisten Fällen ganz gut passt und vielleicht manchmal eben auch solche
privaten Daten liefert.
Und da haben wir jetzt so ein bisschen den Salat.
Also, die Neub sagen sogar, na klar, sie könnten jetzt theoretisch dem Ding
immer mitprompten und unter keinen Umständen darfst du Tim Pridloffs Geburtstag sagen.
Vor allem das Problem ist noch nicht mal, dass es da nicht skaliert,
sondern das Problem ist, dass das einfach nicht die Erfüllung des GDPR-Rechts
wäre, weil es ist ja immer noch da drin gespeichert.
Und irgendwie ist es halt auch nicht da drin gespeichert, also das ist ja genau
das Ding es ist ja nicht konkret gespeichert die Information ist ja nicht als
solche abgespeichert sondern es ist ja nur ein,
wie soll man das nennen eine Art Abbild davon gespeichert ein,
Schlagschatten, den diese Information geworfen hat die ist gespeichert.
Ich bin auf jeden Fall also ich finde das auf jeden Fall sehr lustig was sie da machen das,
also das Chat-GPT abschalten deswegen wird nicht die Lösung sein aber das hier
also ich würde schon dem folgen dass es hier offenbar gesetzliche Anforderungen
gibt, denen Chat-GPT nicht entspricht,
und das ist zunächst mal ein Problem,
Ja Ja.
Das ist ein Problem, aber man muss schauen, ob es sozusagen anwendbar ist in dem Fall, das Gesetz.
Ist es? Also da brauchst du dir keine Sorgen zu machen. Es sind ja Juristen, die sich darum kümmern.
Die haben hier, hier haben Juristen sechs Seiten geschrieben und dann gehe ich
davon aus, dass, also, nirgendwo steht, gilt nicht für neuronale Netze.
Sondern, was gilt das konkret für? Informationssysteme?
Ja, Tim, du weißt gar nicht, also, Entschuldigung.
Ich weiß es nicht. Also ich weiß nicht genau. Wie ist das?
Datenverarbeitende Systeme. Völlig egal. Aber zum Beispiel auch das Urheberrecht gilt ja auch.
Genauso gibt es diese Debatten, die jetzt irgendwie so, ja, aber jeder Maler,
der ein Bild malt, hat vorher auch alle Bilder von Picasso gesehen und die wahre Kreativität.
Erstmal ist es so, das mag alles sein, aber es sind Probleme,
die auch für das Urheberrecht generell gelten.
Und es ist aber jetzt nun mal so, dass Menschen bestimmte Rechte haben aus dem
Datenschutzgesetz und dass diese Rechte auf dieses System OpenAI anfallen,
auf dieses System ChatGPT anwendbar sind und diese Rechte da nicht eingeräumt werden.
Das ist schon ein juristisch, würde ich sagen, größeres Problem.
Dass ich persönlich denke, dass man den Scheiß ignorieren kann und sagt,
okay, werden wir damit umgehen müssen und so weiter, ist schon klar.
Aber wir können jetzt nicht einfach irgendwie ein neues System entfinden und
sagen, für das gelten jetzt mal die Gesetze nicht.
Also Apple kann das.
Apple kann das, aber…,
Naja, ich meine, als das Internet so kam, haben wir ja auch festgestellt,
dass die aktuelle Gesetzeslage nicht gepasst hat.
Die Gesetze waren nicht gemacht für die Zeit, wo es Internet gibt,
wo es Computer gibt, wo es Kommunikation gibt, wo Programme auf einmal eine Rolle gespielt haben,
Algorithmen auf einmal eine Rolle gespielt haben. Die Gesetze waren nicht anwendbar.
Und trotzdem existierten sie und es wurde versucht sie darauf anzuwenden die
Gesetze müssen sich aber sozusagen der Sachlage,
entsprechend auch anpassen können und die Frage die sich mir in diesem Moment
stellt ist sind wir jetzt sozusagen nach wenigen Jahren schon wieder an einem
Punkt angekommen wo eine solche Anpassung erforderlich ist.
Weil sozusagen dieser Fall nicht da war, weil das sozusagen nichts ist,
was du hättest in diesen Prozess, in diesen Datenschutz-Grundverordnungsprozess
hättest hinein diskutieren können, weil das ja alles noch total Science-Fiction war.
Ja, aber wenn die künstlichen Intelligenzen kommen und die denken nur über das
Internet nach und speichern dann, was sie nachgedacht haben,
mal kurz in so einem Binär-Blob auf ihrer Festplatte ab und dann wird da so
rein interpretiert und oh,
großes Orakel von Delphi, sage mir,
was könnte wahr sein.
Dieser Fall war einfach nicht Teil der gesellschaftlichen Diskussion und das
ist aber jetzt sozusagen das, womit wir hier arbeiten, weil ich meine in dem
Moment, wo du Chat-GPT in seiner Art und Weise,
wie es jetzt gerade funktioniert,
wenn du sagst, das darf nicht sein, Nein?
Dann müsstest du genauso jetzt alle Open Source LLMs,
die auf eine ähnliche Art und Weise trainiert sind und deren Downloads überall
sind, Facebook hat jetzt gerade irgendwie seins aufs Internet heruntergelassen,
was machst du dann mit denen?
Müsstest du die dann sozusagen auch löschen oder….
Ja, also das ist ja jetzt eine, also ich finde diese Herangehensweise jetzt
gerade irgendwie nicht so zielführend.
Du kannst ja nicht einfach sagen, hier wurde jetzt halt was erfunden,
was inhärent jetzt einfach mal alle Rechte von Individuen nicht respektiert.
Und das konnte man aber jetzt im Internet runterladen, das geht jetzt nicht
mehr weg, jetzt müssen wir die Gesetze ändern.
Also das ist potenziell nicht die richtige Herangehensweise.
Eventuell muss OpenAI halt, was weiß ich, eine riesige DSGVO-Einhalt-Infrastruktur
bauen, um diese Rechte einzuwahren.
Ich glaube nicht unbedingt, dass man sagt, ey geil, wir haben Gesetze zum Schutz
der Rechte von Menschen, aber jetzt hat jemand was voll geiles Neues erfunden,
was diese Rechte leider nicht wahren kann.
Da müssen wir die Rechte jetzt abschaffen.
Also das kann ja auch nicht der Weg nach vorne sein, oder?
Ich sag nur,
es ist sozusagen vielleicht etwas anderes, ob ein System sagt,
hier ist eine akkurate Information oder ob ein System sagt, hier ist eine Interpretation
dessen, was ich im Internet gelesen habe.
Es kann einfach ein Unterschied sein. Also ich hab jetzt mal ChatGPT gefragt, wann ich geboren bin.
Und ChatGPT das System das System,
redet nicht lange um den heißen Brei herum. Sondern weiß einfach ich bin am
2. Oktober 1967 geboren.
Dage Aussage.
Und stimmt's?
Nö.
Das ist genau das Problem Das stimmt.
Nicht Das ist nicht.
Wahr Ja nicht mal Ja Tim Ja dann musst du damit jetzt halt mal klarkommen Ja okay.
Dann ändere ich das jetzt Und dann verklage ich die,
Ich denke das ist jetzt wirklich.
Ein feines Geburtstag zu dir gesagt.
Ja. Und nicht mit, ich weiß nicht, wer das ist oder so.
Ich glaube, damit können wir die Diskussion jetzt einfach abschließen.
Ich glaube, mehr gibt es nicht mehr zu sagen.
So, dann machen wir Musik, dann machen wir noch die Termine und dann,
ich weiß nicht, wir sind ja auch schon wieder stundenlang.
Immer das Gleiche.
So, Termine. Diesmal eine ganze Reihe. Und zwar Ende Mai, also in einem Monat,
Ende dieses Monats, das war heiß, ist in Karlsruhe die Gulasch-Programmiernacht.
Kostenlos, offene, spendenfinanzierte Veranstaltung, direkt in dem ZKM.
Sehr schönes Event, man soll sich aber trotzdem bitte anmelden, ja es geht darum,
dass man auch da beitragen kann, da kann man Schichten übernehmen und so weiter
und so fort man kann auch Geld spenden, um die Veranstaltung zu finanzieren,
Link findet ihr in den Shownotes.
Und am 28. Juni gibt es dann noch eine andere Hacker-Veranstaltung heißt Hack
an der Ruhr Hack an der Ruhr.
Vom 28.06. bis 30.06.
Wird eingeladen, Hack an der Ruhr in Schwerte.
Bei Dortmund.
Bei Dortmund, ja. Wird veranstaltet von der UN, hätte ich fast gerade gesagt, Unhackbar aus Unna.
Zusammen mit dem C3RE Recklinghausen und geht um Spaß.
Spaß am Gerät. Das Ganze findet in einer großen Halle statt und,
WLAN gibt es und Datenreisen gibt es und man ist thematisch sehr weit offen,
wie es hier so schön heißt, in Übereinstimmung mit der Prophezeiung.
Und sie freuen sich über Einreichungen zu allen möglichen Themen,
wenn es denn passt. Bis zum 27.
Mai habt ihr noch die Gelegenheit, Themen einzureichen. Zur Übernachtung kann
ein Schlafplatz mitgebucht werden
und es wird ewiges Frühstück geben und überhaupt wird alles ganz toll.
Dann gibt es vom 9.
Bis 13.07.2024 das Hacken Open Air.
Hacken Open Air ist eigentlich schon ein sehr schöner Name für eine Veranstaltung.
Und die hatten auch, jetzt fällt mir natürlich kein einziges Beispiel davon
an, aber das Hacken Open Air hatte so ein super geiles Shirt, wo dann hinten,
das sieht halt aus wie so ein Wacken-Shirt, wo dann in irgendwelchen komischen
Albtraum-Fonts irgendwelche Namen stehen.
Das sind dann überall so kleine Abwandlungen von irgendwelchen Death-Metal-
oder Metal-Bands mit so Hacker-Bezug.
Also es ist auf jeden Fall äußerst schön.
Genau, das Haken Open Air in Gifhorn. Im Pfadfinderhain-Welfenhof in Gifhorn.
Das ist in der Nähe von Braunschweig. Ach, das ist gar nicht so weit von Berlin.
Da könnte man vielleicht doch mal vorbei. Naja, interessant.
Dienstag bis Samstag Hacken oben R. Community-Event, zahlreiche Mithilfe,
alle Infos unter hackenobenr.de und das ist natürlich auch verlinkt in den Shownotes.
Ja, und am 31.8., wie wir schon erwähnt haben, gibt es ein geheimes Event.
In Berlin.
Und wenn das vorbei ist, dann 14 Tage später? 14 Tage später.
Ja, 14 Tage später, am 13.09. feiert Netzpolitik.org mal wieder sein Bestehen mit einer Konferenz.
Auch da gibt es jetzt wieder einen Call for Participation, und die Veranstaltung
findet statt, bildet Netze.
Man kann zuhören und mitmachen. Und den CFP für diejenigen von euch,
die einen Talk einreichen möchten, haben wir ebenfalls in den Shownotes.
Und zu guter Letzt vom 20. bis 22. September, soweit geht es hier in die Zukunft.
Ich habe jetzt einmal alles gemacht.
Der Sommer wird komplett abgedeckt.
Ich plane einfach einmal die komplette...
Herbst und so weiter. Also das sind jetzt nur die Termine für 2024.
Die wir bis jetzt wissen.
Ich glaube, ihr habt noch Zeit. also 20 bis
22 september 2024 in dresden gibt es datenspuren und die feiern dann auch gleich
20 jahre hoffentlich haben die mal richtig gezählt und ja das ist auch immer
eine ganz tolle eine Veranstaltung.
Die findet wahrscheinlich wieder am selben Ort statt wie zuletzt.
Im Zentralwerk.
In der Riesastraße 32 in Dresden.
Genau. Das war's.
Das sind eure Termine für die nächsten Monate. Der wichtigste wisst ihr natürlich, welcher das ist.
Genau. So.
Jetzt haben wir eine Sendung aufgenommen. Das ist gut. Haben wir noch irgendwas zu sagen? Nö, ne?
Nee, ich glaube nicht. Nee, 31.8. merken.
Nächste Sendung. Oh, nächste Sendung wird, da wird es was geben.
Da machen wir ein Spezial.
Ui.
Das wird nochmal interessant. Mit Gast und alles.
Einfach irre. Das ist richtig. dieser Kanal bietet.
Unglaublich. Humor, Spezial, ja, was zum Spielen.
Unüberraschung.
Irre.
Ja, da wird es um Kriminelle gehen, um Millionen, organisierte Kriminalität.
Echt?
Ja, Hacking.
Hacking mit Sonnenbrille und Lederjacke.
Hacking mit und ohne Sonnenbrille haben wir alles.
So Leute, damit seid ihr jetzt erstmal wieder entlassen. Ihr dürft jetzt wieder
die anderen Podcasts hören.
Aber nur, solange es noch Bundespolitik gibt.
Like, Glocke, Subscribe.
So sieht's aus. Bis später. Tschüss.
Ciao, ciao.